ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE ON
CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY. LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION WILL BEGIN NOW.
THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE ON CORRECTIONS,
PUBLIC SAFETY, JUDICIARY, LABOR
AND TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL INCLUDE UPDATES ON PREVIOUS
BUDGET ACTIONS, STARTING WITH
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES, AND THEN HEARING FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION IN THE OFFICE
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL. PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ALL ISSUES WILL BE
HEARD AFTER ALL, DISCUSSION
ISSUES AND THEN WE WILL MOVE TO
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR TO ENSURE
WE HAVE TIME FOR EVERYTHING. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA, WE ARE ASKING
PANELISTS TO KEEP THEIR
TESTIMONY UNDER FIVE MINUTES. I
WOULD ALSO ASK MY FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS CONCISE,
AS WOULD ANY MEMBERS LIKE TO ADD
ANYTHING. BEFORE WE BEGIN SEEING
NONE, LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATORS WILLIAM HERE, DURAZZO
NEWMAN. CIERTO HERE. ALL RIGHT.
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED,
LET'S BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
DISCUSSION ITEM, ISSUE NUMBER
30, AN OVERVIEW OF THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE
PLANNING REPORT PREPARED BY CAL
OES. SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM ERIC SWANSON, THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FINANCE AND
ADMINISTRATION, FROM THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES. YOU WILL
BE TIMED. THANK YOU, I'M ERIC
SWANSON, DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION AT
CAL OES. AND WITH ME TODAY IS
TINA CURRY, OUR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. THE FIRST ISSUE ON
YOUR AGENDA IS A REQUIREMENT
ARTICULATED IN THE LAST FEW
BUDGET CYCLES FOR CAL OES TO
ISSUE A REPORT THAT IS FOCUSED
ON EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE PLANNING. THE INTENT TO
THIS REPORT IS TO IDENTIFY THE
TYPES OF RISKS CAL OES CONSIDERS
DURING PLAN PLANNING AND
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS, THE
FRAMEWORK UTILIZED TO IDENTIFY
THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCE
CAPABILITIES. EXISTING PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT THAT FRAMEWORK, THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. HOW RECENTLY
APPROVED RESOURCES SUPPORT THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND GAPS THAT MAY
EXIST WITH THE CURRENT
RESOURCES. THAT'S A MOUTHFUL,
BUT THAT WAS ALL IN THE
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE UTILIZED
INTERNAL INTERVIEWS AND OUTSIDER
STAKEHOLDER INPUT TO DEVELOP
THIS REPORT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, THE STATE HAS
EXPERIENCED AN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS SEVERE DROUGHT,
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES, POWER
GRID OUTAGE CHALLENGES,
EARTHQUAKES, COVID 19, AND
INTENSIVE STORMS WITH SEVERE
FLOODING THE LAST FEW YEARS, 15
OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY HAVE
OCCURRED SINCE 2015, WITH SEVEN
OF THOSE OCCURRING IN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS. THE DISASTER
LANDSCAPE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION HAS BEEN
CHANGING, INCREASING IN SCALE
AND SEVERITY. A FOUNDATION OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IN THE
STATE IS THE CONCEPT OF NEIGHBOR
HELPING NEIGHBOR UNDERSTANDING
THAT NO AREA WILL NECESSARILY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MANAGE LARGE
SCALE DISASTERS ON THEIR OWN
WITHIN CALIFORNIA, SCALABILITY
AND SURGE CAPACITY FOR
EMERGENCIES IS ROOTED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER MUTUAL AID
AGREEMENT. THIS AGREEMENT ALLOWS
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE TO SHARE RESOURCES AS
NEEDED DURING DISASTER RESPONSE.
ALL CITIES, COUNTIES, AND WHAT
WE CALL OPERATIONAL AREAS HAVE A
BUILT IN ESCALATION PROCESS. IF
THE RESPONSE EFFORTS EXCEED
THEIR CAPABILITIES IN ITS ROLE
OF STATEWIDE COORDINATION, CAL
OES SUPPORTS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
AND COMMUNITIES THROUGH PLANNING
AND PREPAREDNESS ACTIVITIES,
TRAINING, AND THE FULL CYCLE OF
EMERGENCIES FROM IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE THROUGH LONG TERM
RECOVERY. DURING THIS PROCESS,
CAL OES COORDINATES THE RESPONSE
ACTIONS OF STATE GOVERNMENT AND
SERVES AS THE STATE'S OVERALL
COORDINATOR TO SECURE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RESOURCES THROUGH
FEMA AND RESOURCES FROM OTHER
STATES. THIS REPORT OUTLINES HOW
OUR PROGRESS PROGRAMS FIT INTO
THE STATE DISASTER FRAMEWORK,
INCLUDING SOME OF THE MOST
RECENT INVESTMENTS THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE HAS MADE, WHICH
INCLUDES A PERMANENT INCIDENT
SUPPORT TEAM, INCREASE THE
CAPABILITIES OF OUR 24 HOUR
WARNING CENTER, STRONG STATE
REGIONAL SUPPORT FOR DISASTER
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY, EXPANDED
FIRE FLEET AND SEARCH AND RESCUE
RESOURCES AND OTHERS.
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS ARE DESIGNED
TO BE FLEXIBLE AND SCALABLE TO
PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
RESPONSE FOR EACH DISASTER. WE
EXPERIENCE WAS BORN OF OUR PAST
EXPERIENCE AND OUR DURABLE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. WE ARE MORE
PREPARED THAN MANY OTHER STATES
TO RESPOND TO FUTURE EVENTS, AND
THROUGH OUR STATE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM, WE AID IN THE RESPONSE
AND RECOVERY OF DISASTERS THAT
OCCUR IN OTHER STATES, SUCH AS
WE DID IN MAUI AFTER THE FIRES
LAST YEAR. THAT SAID, THE
DISASTER LANDSCAPE IS DYNAMIC
AND THE ABILITY TO ADJUST
QUICKLY TO ADDRESS NEEDS. IT IS
CRUCIAL TO THE ABILITY TO
RECOVER FROM THESE INCIDENTS. A
TRAINED LOCAL DISASTER WORKFORCE
IS CRITICAL AND WE HAVE A STRONG
TRAINING STRUCTURE, BUT THE COST
OF TRAINING CAN BE A BARRIER FOR
LOCALS. LIKEWISE THE MATCH COSTS
FOR LOCAL MITIGATION PROJECTS,
WHICH ARE PREPARING FOR FUTURE
DISASTERS CAN ALSO BE
PROHIBITIVE AND THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM FOR APPROVING SUCH
PROJECTS CAN BE LENGTHY AND
CUMBERSOME. WE ARE ONLY TOUCHING
ON A FEW POINTS IN THIS REPORT,
BUT I'M MINDFUL OF OUR TIME
CONSTRAINTS. AS YOU REMINDED ME
EARLIER, MISS CURRY AND I ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU, I DO
APPRECIATE IT. I'M GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ASK IF LAO HAS ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. CHAIR
WAHAB, MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JARED
SIPPEL. I'M WITH THE LAO. BASED
ON OUR REVIEW OF THE REPORT, WE
FIND THAT THE CONTENTS GENERALLY
ADDRESS THE STATUTES
REQUIREMENTS. AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT OES IDENTIFIES ITS
STRATEGIC GOALS AS WELL AS GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES FOR RESPONDING TO
INDIVIDUAL EMERGENCIES AND FOR
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS. I THINK WHERE
WE HAD HOPED TO SEE MORE IS THAT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF SPECIFIC
GOALS, OBJECTIVES AND METRICS
FOR ENHANCING THE STATE'S
OVERARCHING EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPACITY. WE THINK THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE LEGISLATURE TO BETTER
EVALUATE OES BUDGET PROPOSALS IN
THE FUTURE. AS SUCH, GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND METRICS COULD
HAVE INCLUDED THE NUMBER AND
TYPES OF EMERGENCIES THE STATE
NEEDS TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
TYPES AND LEVELS OF RESOURCES
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THOSE EMERGENCIES, GOALS FOR
RESPONSE TIMES OR GOALS AND
TARGETS FOR KEY RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. AND THEN WE BELIEVE
THAT WITH THIS INFORMATION, THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE BETTER
POSITIONED TO DETERMINE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH OES EXISTING
CAPACITY IS INSUFFICIENT AND
WHETHER OES GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
ARE ALIGNED WITH THAT OF THE
LEGISLATURE. MOREOVER, WE THINK
AGAIN THAT THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO BETTER ASSESS OES
BUDGET PROPOSALS IN THE FUTURE.
SO WE CONTINUE TO THINK THAT
THIS IS IMPORTANT, AND WE HOPE
OES WILL INCLUDE THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION IN ITS FUTURE BUDGET
PROPOSALS, SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS WELL POSITIONED
TO ASSESS THEIR MERITS. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TESTER. COME BACK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS, BUT
NO COMMENTS. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT I'M GOING TO MOVE THIS ON
TO OUR COMMITTEE PANELS, I DO
HAVE SOME COMMENTS. I DO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT, CALIFORNIA'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY
RELIES ON MUTUAL AID BETWEEN
LOCAL ENTITIES. SPECIFICALLY, I
SERVED ON THE CITY OF HAYWARD
COUNCIL, I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
VÆ DANGEROUS THE WAY THAT MUTUAL
AID POTENTIALLY WORKS,
ESPECIALLY KNOWING ORGANIZED
CRIME IS VERY INFORMED IN SOME
OF OUR PROCESSES. SO FOR
EXAMPLE, IN OUR CITY, WE HAVE
NINE PATROL UNITS OF A CITY OF
160,000. RIGHT, AND WHEN
ORGANIZED CRIME HITS ALONG A
FREEWAY AND MULTIPLE CITIES,
ASKING FOR MUTUAL AID AND AGAIN,
ADDITIONAL POLICE RESPONSE HERE
OR THERE OR ANYWHERE, IT'S A
LITTLE BIT PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
IT'S IT CAN BE ORGANIZED AND
TARGETED IN A DIFFERENT WAY AS
WELL, SO I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT. I'M ALSO VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW MANY
AMBULANCES WE HAVE, PER COUNTY,
I BELIEVE, IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY, AND YOU CAN'T QUOTE
ME EXACTLY ON THE NUMBER, BUT I
BELIEVE IT WAS ROUGHLY ABOUT SIX
AMBULANCES IN MY COUNTY, LARGELY
FOCUSED IN, I'M GOING TO SAY,
LARGELY OAKLAND AND BERKELEY
AREA VERSUS THE SOUTHERN COUNTY,
AND THERE HAS TO BE MORE EFFORT
AND MORE OF A PUSH, EVEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVELS, IF WE'RE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THIS. RIGHT, WE
HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT FAILURES
IN COVID, RIGHT? I THINK IT
CLEARLY SHOWED THAT WE ARE NOT
AT THAT LEVEL TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE CONCERNS.
I THINK NØ REAL NATION IS, AND
THERE'S MONEY ON THE TABLE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL, AND I'M
HOPING THAT YOU GUYS APPLY TO
EVERY SINGLE GRANT, EVERY SINGLE
PROGRAM THAT IS AVAILABLE. AND,
AND CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE WE
HAVE 40 MILLION PEOPLE THAT RELY
ON IT, AS WELL AS ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE, STREAMLINING
THAT YOU GUYS CAN DO OFTEN
TIMES, YOU KNOW, WORKING
GOVERNMENT, MOST PEOPLE DO IT IN
THE SENSE OF THIS IS THE WAY
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE IT, SO NOW
WE'RE AGAIN IN THE 21ST CENTURY
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS
DONE PRETTY QUICKLY, YOU KNOW,
WHEN PEOPLE ARE REQUESTING
SERVICES OR ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AND, AND MUCH MORE
NEEDS TO BE STREAMLINED. AND I
STILL DON'T SEE THAT YET. TO BE
COMPLETELY FRANK, AND SO I DO
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT. AND
THEN OUR STATE LEVEL FIRE AND
RESCUE FLEETS WAS, WAS NEEDED TO
SUPPLEMENT LOCAL RESOURCES,
RIGHT, AND SO HOW DID OES DECIDE
THAT? SO LET ME I'M SORRY. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR QUESTION. SO YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE ACTUAL
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAD? YEAH.
YEAH. SO IF I CAN TALK JUST
BRIEFLY. WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
TINA CURRY, CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS FOR CAL
OES, I, I AGREE. I MEAN THE
REPORT, I HOPE HIGHLIGHTS THE,
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE THAT'S IN PLACE,
INCLUDING MUTUAL AID, BUT ALSO
HOW CONDITIONS HAVE CHANGED AND
EVOLVE. AND WE HAVE TO BE
MINDFUL OF THAT EXACTLY AS YOU
POINTED OUT, AS, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER IT'S SAFETY OR THE TYPES
OF INCIDENTS THAT WE'RE CALLING
MUTUAL AID FOR. SO WE HAVE TO BE
FLEXIBLE TO CONTINUE TO EVOLVE
AND BUILD AND LEARN FROM
LESSONS. IN TERMS OF THE
RESOURCE REQUEST, CAL OES, AS
PART OF THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM ON
THE FIRE SIDE, GOES A LITTLE BIT
FARTHER IN THAT WE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT WHERE THE STATE
PROVIDES, YOU KNOW, OVER 270
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT, ACTUAL FIRE
ENGINES OF DIFFERENT TYPES THAT
ARE PURCHASED BY THE STATE THAT
ARE MAINTAINED BY THE STATE, BUT
THEY'RE OPERATED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SO IT'S TRULY A
PARTNERSHIP. SO THE PROPOSAL, I
BELIEVE UNLESS I'M WRONG AND
ERIC WILL CORRECT ME IF I AM,
WAS THAT WE NEEDED TO DO MORE TO
ENSURE THAT THE MAINTENANCE OF
THAT EQUIPMENT WAS KEEPING UP
WITH WHAT THE DEMANDS ARE. SO
WITH ALL OF THE INCREASE IN
DISASTERS AND FIRES LASTING
LONGER, MORE FREQUENT AND
LARGER, THAT OBVIOUSLY INCREASES
THE WEAR AND TEAR ON THAT MUTUAL
AID EQUIPMENT THAT WE SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY WITH, WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SO THAT WAS REALLY
KIND OF VERY, VERY BRIEFLY, IN A
NUTSHELL, WHAT THAT PROPOSAL
ADDRESSED. BUT IT'S ALSO TO
SUPPORT THIS LONG STANDING
PARTNERSHIP ON THE FIRE AND
RESCUE THAT'S BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE, BECAUSE IT TRULY IS
THE STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEANING IN TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF SURGE CAPACITY
THAT WE'VE CALLED ON TIME AND
TIME AGAIN TO ADDRESS, TO
ADDRESS NOT JUST WILDFIRE, BUT
OTHER NATURAL HAZARDS, INCLUDING
FLOODS AND OTHER OTHER EVENTS
THAT THAT AFFECT YOUR
COMMUNITIES. SO DURING MAJOR
PUBLIC SAFETY EVENTS, WHAT IS
THE ROLE OF CAL OES LAW
ENFORCEMENT VERSUS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SUCH AS THE
DOJ AND SO FORTH, WELL, WE HAVE
LIKE IN ALL OF OUR AREAS, WE
HAVE A BROAD PARTNERSHIP TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACROSS TO
OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OF COURSE,
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE ARE
TALKING WITH THEM ALL THE TIME.
WE'RE PLANNING WITH THEM. MAKE
SURE WE UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER'S
ROLES. YOU KNOW, WHETHER IT'S ON
THE INVESTIGATIVE SIDE VERSUS
THE PURE MUTUAL AID, LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE, SO WE ARE
EXPECT AND TO MAINTAIN THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS AND TO LEVERAGE
THEM TO THEIR MAXIMUM EFFECT
BECAUSE, AGAIN, IT ONLY WORKS
WHEN ALL OF THE THINGS WORK
TOGETHER AND SUPPORT THE SURGE
CAPACITY THAT OUR, OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED. SO, SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WITH THE OUR EMBEDDED
LAW ENFORCEMENT GROUP THAT IS
WITHIN OUR AGENCY MAINTAINS
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS ACROSS THE
BOARD AND IN ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. OKAY SO FOR EXAMPLE,
DOES CAL OES, YOU KNOW, KNOW HOW
MANY AMBULANCES OR FIRE TRUCKS
ARE AVAILABLE IN A GIVEN REGION
OF THE STATE? WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH ANSWERS. YES. WE ARE. WE
ONE OF OUR KEY PARTNERS IS THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY, AS WELL AS TO THE
EXTENT THAT EMS IS EMBEDDED
WITHIN FIRE DEPARTMENTS, TO
ALWAYS BE MINDFUL OF THAT SYSTEM
AND WHAT MIGHT BE NEEDED FROM
IT, THERE'S A MUTUAL AID SYSTEM
THAT IS EXISTS THAT IS JUST FOR
MEDICAL HEALTH. THAT INCLUDES
THE EMS AUTHORITY. SO WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENS OR WE'RE
PLANNING FOR SOMETHING, WE'RE,
WE'RE EXPECTED TO AND DO HAVE
THE EMS PROGRAMS IN LOCKSTEP
SIDE BY SIDE WITH US TO
UNDERSTAND, BECAUSE IT ALL HAS
TO WORK TOGETHER. IT'S NEVER ONE
THING, IT'S NEVER JUST EMS OR
JUST FIRE. AND SO WE, YOU KNOW,
AGAIN, WE ARE WE'RE MAINTAINING
AND LEVERAGING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THOSE STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE
THE CONNECTIVITY TO THOSE LOCAL
RESOURCES. SO WE ARE MANAGING
SURGE, NOT JUST FOR FIRE AND
LAW. AND THE THINGS THAT ARE
UNDER OES UMBRELLA, BUT ALL OF
THE LINES OF EFFORT THAT COME
TOGETHER IN A DISASTER. SO I DO
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, I STATED MY
HOME COUNTY HAS ROUGHLY ABOUT
SIX AMBULANCES OR SO, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY ARE IN OUR
LOCAL CITY. WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE POPULATION,
THE, THE DENSITY Kò AND MUCH
MORE, WITH THE AMOUNT OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE ARE INVESTING
IN STATEWIDE ACROSS THE BOARD,
DOESN'T MATTER WHICH AGENCY WE
HAVE BEEN INVESTING
SIGNIFICANTLY IN TECHNOLOGY AND
BEING ABLE TO PINPOINT
POTENTIALLY WHERE AND WHEN YOU
KNOW, A DISASTER CAN OCCUR, YOU
KNOW HOW FAR IT'S GOING TO GO,
HOW QUICKLY IT'S GOING TO
SPREAD, YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS IN THE
RESPONSE STILL, AND WE'RE SEEING
CALIFORNIA DEAL WITH MORE
NATURAL DISASTERS, REGULARLY
YEAR OVER YEAR. WE'RE SEEING IT.
AND LUCKILY, WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
RAIN AND A LOT OF WATER COME
INTO THE STATE, BUT WITH THESE
REPORTS AND WITH THE DATA AND
WITH THE, YOU KNOW, INFUSION OF
CASH AND SO FORTH IN SOME OF
THESE EFFORTS, I THINK THAT IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THE RESIDENTS ARE EXPECTING
FASTER TURNAROUNDS, FASTER
RESPONSE TIMES, FASTER
IMPROVEMENTS. SO I DO JUST WANT
TO STRESS THAT, I WANT TO SEE IF
MY, SENATOR SARDO HAS ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AS I THINK
I CAN PROBABLY COMMENT ON SOME
OF THE DISASTER RESPONSE. BUT A
LOT OF WHAT YOU DO IS COORDINATE
ON A LARGER STATE LEVEL, WHEN A
LOCAL AGENCY IS OVERWHELMED,
THEY GO TO THE COUNTY LEVEL. THE
COUNTY IS OVERWHELMED, THEY GO
TO THE STATE LEVEL. SO THERE ARE
SEVERAL LAYERS THAT GO, BETWEEN
WHEN THERE'S A LOCAL EMERGENCY
AND THAT. AND, EMS IS WHO WE
REPORT TO EVERY DAY, NOT WE
ANYMORE, BUT THEY REPORT TO YOU
EVERY DAY. HOW MANY WHAT KIND OF
EQUIPMENT IS AVAILABLE. AND SO
ALL OF THAT'S DONE BY THE AREA,
AREA COORDINATORS. SO THIS IS
LIKE AREA G IS DIFFERENT FROM
AREA E. AND SO THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT COORDINATE. BUT WHEN
IT GOES LARGER AND WE NEED TO
START CALLING IN STATE RESOURCES
FOR A LARGER STATE RESPONSE. IN
OTHER WORDS, IF IT'S A WIDE AREA
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
THEY ARE MILES AND MILES AHEAD
OF WHERE WE USED TO BE, THE
ENGINES THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE EMBEDDED INTO ALL OF
OUR DIFFERENT, FIRE STATIONS.
AND THEY ARE ARE ACTUALLY
MAINTAINED BY THE FIRE. THE
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT HOUSE THOSE
ENGINES. SO SO THERE'S TWO,
THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO SAY. ONE
IS THAT ALSO WHEN OTHER STATES
HELP US WITH MUTUAL AID AS WELL,
I DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THREE WEEK ROTATION, YOU KNOW,
MAYBE WE CAN ADDRESS SOME OF
THAT AS WELL, BECAUSE THE MOMENT
THAT WE TRAIN UP THE OTHER
STATES TO HELP US, THEY DIP OUT
AND ANOTHER STATE COMES IN. SO
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A PROBLEM
THAT, YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS AND FIGURE OUT
POTENTIALLY A, A BETTER SYSTEM,
A LONGER TERM SYSTEM. NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO IS ALSO THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT COME IN THE
DOLLAR, 50 TO EVERY DOLLAR WE
SPEND ON OUR EQUIPMENT TO ENSURE
THAT WHETHER IT'S THE LOCAL
CITIES OR WHETHER IT'S ANY OTHER
AGENCY, THAT IT'S PROTECTED FOR
THE ACTUAL EQUIPMENT REIMBURSED
AND THE PROPER THINGS THAT IT'S
UTILIZED FOR. SO I DO JUST WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS IS A
PERSONAL, PET ISSUE OF MINE THAT
I DEEPLY CARE ABOUT. SO, JUST
HIGHLIGHTING THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. BUT YOU'RE ALSO NEED
TO KEEP IN MIND WHAT NATIONAL
RESOURCES VERSUS STATE VERSUS
LOCAL VERSUS 100. YEAH, BUT THEY
ALL WILL GET REIMBURSED AND THEY
ALL WORK TOGETHER TO FULFILL
THAT ROLE. AND THEY THEY CANNOT
DICTATE WHAT THE NATIONAL,
EMERGENCY SERVICES. BUT HOW THE
FUNDS ARE UTILIZED, HOW OUR
FUNDS ARE UTILIZED FOR OUR STATE
PURPOSES. YES. BECAUSE IF WE'RE
GOING TO IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ROTATIONS OF CREWS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT, YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
WE STILL HAVE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
STAFF. AND SO THAT'S WHY A LOT
OF THIS, A LOT OF IT'S DONE THE
WAY IT'S DONE AND IT'S BEEN
YEARS AND YEARS OF TRYING TO PUT
IT TOGETHER. SO IT ACTUALLY
WORKS NOW. AND, AND SO, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
IMPROVEMENTS THEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SPENDING MASSIVE AMOUNTS
OF MONEY OVER, OVER STAFFING,
FOR, FOR EMERGENCIES. BECAUSE
WHEN THOSE GUYS GO OUT FOR THREE
WEEKS ON A CREW, A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE STAY IN TOWN AND WORK FOR
THREE WEEKS IN A ROW AND A
STATION, SO, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
NO EASY THERE'S NO GREAT WAY
WHEN WE'RE HAVING A BIG
EMERGENCY. AND THAT'S WHY THEY
RELY ON PEOPLE TO KIND OF TAKE
CARE OF THEMSELVES A LITTLE BIT.
AND 100. I'M NOT SEEING AS MUCH
OF A DRAW SHORTAGE IN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AS YOU MIGHT BE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
YOUR REGION WITH THAT STUFF,
BUT, HAVING ACTUALLY WORKED IN
THE SYSTEM, I CAN TELL YOU THE
SYSTEM IS A WHOLE LOT BETTER
THAN IT USED TO BE. AND THE
PARTS THAT WILL WOULD IMPROVE IT
ARE PRETTY DARN COSTLY. AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT EQUIPMENT
JUST SITTING AROUND DOING
NOTHING FOR YEARS AND YEARS, AND
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN ONE DAY YOU
GET TO USE IT. YEAH, THAT'S WHAT
WE CAN WE HAVE TO FIND THAT
HAPPY MEDIUM. OTHERWISE WE'RE
GOING TO INCREASE COSTS FOR THAT
WHICH INCREASE COSTS FOR
EVERYTHING IN THE STATE. YEAH.
SO THESE ARE LIVES AT STAKE. SO
AGAIN WE ARE INVESTING HEAVILY
IN OUR NATURAL DISASTERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE ONE MITIGATE
THEM. AND THEN TWO ARE RESPONSE.
AND THE OUTCOME IS BENEFICIAL TO
PEOPLE TO ENSURE THAT LIVES CATS
DOGS HUMANS EVERYONE IS INTACT
AS WELL AS PROPERTY. SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE FAIR
THINGS THAT WE CAN SAY IS THAT
WE DO WANT TO INVEST IN THIS
AREA, REGARDLESS OF WHAT TYPE OF
DISASTER. YEAH. I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT EVEN IN IN MY
REGION, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE, I
BELIEVE A COUPLE OF
INTERNATIONAL SPORTS, EVENTS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE, AND IT
HAS TO HAVE HEIGHTENED SECURITY.
IT HAS TO HAVE, YOU KNOW, A LOT
OF THE LOCAL FOLKS AND
SURROUNDING CITIES, YOU KNOW,
POTENTIALLY SUPPORT THOSE
EFFORTS, SO I DO JUST WANT TO
FLAG IT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE THAT
IN THE YEARS TO COME, WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT. MY AREA IS
ALSO A IT'S CLOSE TO THE HILLS,
BUT IT'S CONSIDERED A SUBURBAN
METRO AREA AND THE FIRES ARE
COMING CLOSER AND CLOSER. AND
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE AS MUCH
DENSITY AS WE DO IT IS BECOMING
MORE PROBLEMATIC. SO AS MUCH AS
WE CAN DO TO MITIGATE AND ENSURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE AVOID ANY OF
THESE ISSUES, ESPECIALLY WITH
THE AMOUNT OF TECHNOLOGY THAT WE
HAVE INVESTED TO KIND OF
HOPEFULLY FORESEE CERTAIN
THINGS. I DO JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
NONE WE CAN MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ITEM. THANK YOU. SO ISSUE NUMBER
31, WILL BE STAFF MISCONDUCT
PROCESS IMPLEMENTATION UPDATE.
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST HEAR FROM
KATINA. EXCUSE ME, CAITLIN
O'NEIL FROM THE LA OFFICE. AND
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
VICE CHAIR FOR A BRIEF MINUTE,
TO CHAIR. DOES HE NEED THE
SCRIPT? NO. MR. CHAIR, VICE
CHAIR? NO THAT'S A GOOD IDEA. I
SECOND THAT. OKAY. LET'S START.
ALL RIGHT. YES. THANK YOU.
CAITLIN O'NEIL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW BY WAY OF PROVIDING
SOME BACKGROUND AND INTRODUCTION
TO THIS ITEM. SO I'M GOING TO
START BY FIRST INTRODUCING TWO
KEY FUNCTIONS WITHIN CDCR AND
ANY PRISON SYSTEM IN GENERAL.
THE FIRST IS THE GRIEVANCE
SYSTEM, WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE IN
PRISON OR ON PAROLE TO CONTEST
DEPARTMENTAL POLICIES, ACTIONS
OR CONDITIONS THAT HAVE A THAT
THEY BELIEVE HAVE AN ADVERSE
EFFECT ON THEIR WELFARE. FOR
EXAMPLE, SOMEONE MIGHT FILE A
GRIEVANCE SAYING THAT THEIR CELL
IS EXCESSIVELY HOT, SO THIS IS
PRIMARILY A PRISON MANAGEMENT
FUNCTION. PRISON AND PAROLE
MANAGEMENT FUNCTION. AND IT'S
OPERATED BY STAFF AT THE PRISONS
AND THE PAROLE DIVISION. THE
SECOND KEY FUNCTION IS INTERNAL
AFFAIRS, WHICH IS PRIMARILY A
HUMAN RESOURCES FUNCTION BECAUSE
IT'S ULTIMATELY ABOUT
DETERMINING WHETHER STAFF
ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT THAT
WARRANTS SOME KIND OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. AND UNLIKE
THE GRIEVANCE SYSTEM, WHICH IS
PRIMARILY A LOCALIZED STAFF BY
LOCAL FOLKS AT THE INSTITUTIONS,
IT IS INTENTIONALLY STAFFED BY A
CENTRALIZED ENTITY THAT IS NOT
WITHIN THE COMMAND STRUCTURE OF
THE PRISONS AND PAROLE TO
PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
INDEPENDENCE. AND IT ALSO HAS
STAFF WITH INVESTIGATORY AND
LEGAL TRAINING. IT'S ALSO
MONITORED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, SO A KEY
CHALLENGE AT THIS AT THE HEART
OF THIS ISSUE IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT ARISE THROUGH THE
GRIEVANCE SYSTEM. SO FOR IN THE
EXAMPLE I GAVE EARLIER ABOUT A
CELL BEING TOO HOT, SUPPOSE THAT
GRIEVANCE SAYS THAT STAFF
ALLEGES THAT OFFICER X PLACED ME
INTENTIONALLY IN THAT CELL, AS A
FORM OF RETALIATION. SO KNOWING
THAT THE CELL GETS EXCESSIVELY
HOT. SO THIS WOULD BE AN
ALLEGATION OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
HISTORICALLY, THESE ALLEGATIONS
THAT ARISE THROUGH THE GRIEVANCE
SYSTEM WERE HANDLED PRIMARILY BY
STAFF, AGAIN AT THE PRISONS AND
IN THE PAROLE DIVISION, AND IN
2019, THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL RAISED
CONCERNS THAT, THESE CASES WERE
BEING WERE NOT BEING HANDLED
PROPERLY. THERE WAS POOR
INVESTIGATORY TECHNIQUES BEING
USED. THE IN THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
HANDLING THEM SHOWED SIGNS OF
BIAS IN FAVOR OF THEIR FELLOW
STAFF MEMBERS, SO SINCE THAT
TIME, CDCR HAS BEEN IN THE
PROCESS OF REVISING HOW,
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
THAT ARISE THROUGH THE GRIEVANCE
PROCESS ARE HANDLED. AND THERE'S
BEEN VARIOUS ITERATIONS. BUT
UNDER THE CURRENT POLICIES, ALL
GRIEVANCES ARE FIRST FORWARDED
TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS TO A NEW TEAM CALLED THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM, THAT
ASSESSES WHETHER OR NOT THEY
CONTAIN ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT, IF THAT TEAM DOES
IDENTIFY ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT, IT THEN. WELL, FIRST
OF ALL, IF THEY IF THEY DON'T
IDENTIFY ALLEGATIONS, THEY'RE
SENT BACK TO THE PRISONS AND
PAROLE DIVISION FOR HANDLING AS
A ROUTINE MATTER. IF THEY DO,
THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES, HOW
SERIOUS ARE THOSE ALLEGATIONS?
AND IF THOSE ALLEGATIONS ARE ON
A LIST CALLED THE ALLEGATION
DECISION INDEX OF MORE SERIOUS
TYPES OF MISCONDUCT, THEN
THEY'RE FORWARDED TO A TEAM
CALLED THE ALLEGATION
INVESTIGATION UNIT WITHIN THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
AN INVESTIGATION. IF NOT,
THEY'RE RETURNED TO THE PRISONS
AND THE PAROLE DIVISION TO BE
HANDLED BY A LOCALLY DESIGNATED
INVESTIGATOR WHO CONDUCTS AN
INQUIRY INTO THE MATTER, AND SO
IN 2023, THERE WERE ABOUT,
180,000 SUCH, GRIEVANCES SENT TO
THIS CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM.
ABOUT 160,000 WERE ROUTED BACK
AS NOT CONTAINING ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT, AND THE
REMAINING ROUGHLY 20,000 ABOUT
HALF STAYED WITH WITH OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR A
INVESTIGATE, AND THE OTHER HALF
ROUGHLY WENT BACK TO, THE
PRISONS AND PAROLE DIVISION FOR
A LOCAL INQUIRY, TO DATE, CDCR
HAS RECEIVED VARIOUS
AUGMENTATIONS TO SUPPORT THESE
NEW PROCESSES, THE CURRENT
ONGOING FUNDING IS AT ABOUT 64
MILLION, AND OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS ALSO RECEIVED
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE EXTERNAL
MONITORING OF THESE NEW
PROCESSES. AND CURRENTLY HAS
ABOUT 15 MILLION FOR THIS
FUNCTION. THANK YOU. YES. YES.
MISSING. YES. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, I'M AMRIK SINGH, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. I'M HERE TO
PROVIDE A SHORT SUMMARY OF OUR
FINDINGS FROM BOTH OUR 2023
ANNUAL REPORT DETAILING OUR
MONITORING OF CDCR STAFF
MISCONDUCT COMPLAINT SCREENING,
INQUIRY, INVESTIGATION AND
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS, WHICH WAS
JUST DESCRIBED AND ABOUT A
REPORT WE PUBLISHED IN JANUARY.
REVIEWING CDCR'S HANDLING OF A
BACKLOG OF GRIEVANCES
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FILED THAT
CONTAINED ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. OUR 2023 ANNUAL
REPORT COVERED THE TIME PERIOD
FROM JANUARY 1ST THROUGH
DECEMBER 31ST, 2023. DURING THAT
TIME, WE MONITORED CDCR'S
PERFORMANCE IN CONDUCTING STAFF
MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS, SCREENING
DECISIONS MADE BY ITS
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM,
ALLEGATION INQUIRY CASES
COMPLETED BY THE PRISONS, LOCAL
INVESTIGATORS, AND
INVESTIGATIONS CONDUCTED BY THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT
AND THE EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINE
PROCESS. FOR THOSE CASES. FOR
EACH OF THE CASES WE MONITORED,
WE ASSESSED THE PERFORMANCE OF
CDCR STAFF AND PROVIDED AN
OVERALL RATING. WE USED AN
ASSESSMENT TOOL THAT CONSISTED
OF FIVE OVERARCHING QUESTIONS,
EACH WITH A SERIES OF SUB
QUESTIONS, AND PROVIDED A RATING
OF SUPERIOR, SATISFACTORY, OR
POOR. STARTING WITH THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM, CDCR
RECEIVED AND SCREENED NEARLY
177,000 COMPLAINTS OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS, THE OIG REVIEWED AND
MONITORED APPROXIMATELY 7000 TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
ROUTED ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT TO THE APPROPRIATE
ENTITY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
OVERALL THE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM PERFORMED IN A
SATISFACTORY MANNER. IN 90% OF
THE CASES WE REVIEWED IN THE 10%
OF THE CASES, THEY PERFORMED
POORLY, RERATED THOSE CASES
POORLY BECAUSE THE TEAM EITHER
FAILED TO IDENTIFY AN ALLEGATION
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT ENTIRELY
REFERRED THE ALLEGATION OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT ON THE ALLEGATION
DECISION INDEX FOR A LOCAL
INQUIRY, RATHER THAN TO THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS,
FAILED TO IDENTIFY THE NEED FOR
CLARIFICATION. INTERVIEWS PRIOR
TO MAKING THAT SCREENING
DECISION, OR IDENTIFIED A SINGLE
ALLEGATION WHEN MULTIPLE PAGE
WHEN MULTIPLE ALLEGATIONS WERE
IN A MULTIPLE PAGE COMPLAINT.
NEXT, OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
LOCAL INQUIRY PROCESS FOUND THAT
CDCR ALSO PERFORMED POORLY OVER
A 12,500 ALLEGATIONS WERE ROUTED
TO THE PRISONS FOR LOCAL
INQUIRIES. WE MONITORED AND
CLOSED 113 CASES BECAUSE WE ARE
NOT YET FULLY STAFFED. WE
MONITORED 89 CASES
CONTEMPORANEOUSLY AND 24 CASES
RETROSPECTIVELY. WE FOUND THAT
OVERALL CDCR'S PERFORMANCE WAS
POOR IN 68% OF THE CASES WE
MONITORED. SOME ISSUES WE
IDENTIFIED WERE THAT CDCR FAILED
TO IMPLEMENT A COHESIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE LOCAL INQUIRY
PROCESS, WHICH RESULTED IN
SYSTEM WIDE FAILURES, CONFUSION
AND FRUSTRATION AMONG STAFF. WE
ALSO IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT
DEFICIENCIES AND GAPS IN POLICY,
WHICH LED TO INSUFFICIENT AND
INCOMPLETE INQUIRIES. SOME
DECISIONS ABOUT ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT WERE INCONSISTENT
WITH THE EVIDENCE. THERE WAS
UNTIMELY CASE PROCESSING AND
FAILURE BY CDCR TO COMMUNICATE
WITH OUR OFFICE, THEREBY DENYING
THE OIG THE ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY CONDUCT ITS
STATUTORY REQUIRED MONITORING.
WE ALSO COMPLETED THE
RETROSPECTIVE REVIEW OF 24
RANDOMLY SELECTED LOCAL INQUIRY
CASES THAT WERE COMPLETED AND
CLOSED WITHIN THE PAST YEAR. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS MONITORING
COMPONENT WAS TO ASSESS CDCR'S
PERFORMANCE. WHEN THE OIG HAD
NOT PROVIDED CONTEMPORANEOUS
MONITORING OF THE 24 CASES, OIG
RATED THE OVERALL PERFORMANCE OF
THE DEPARTMENT POOR. IN 21 OF
THOSE CASES, 88% Þ IGS
RETROSPECTIVE REVIEWS REVEAL
THAT LOCALLY DESIGNATED
INVESTIGATORS FAILED TO COMPLETE
THOROUGH INQUIRIES AND
ALLEGATION INQUIRY REPORTS WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY AT A SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER RATE THAN WHEN WE WERE
ACTUALLY MONITORING THOSE CASES.
MOVING ON TO THE STAFF
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS, CDCR.
COMPLETED 7124, A LITTLE OVER
7100 INVESTIGATIONS IN 2023. WE
MONITORED AND CLOSED 121 STAFF
MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS AND
THE EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS FOR THOSE CASES, WE
FOUND THAT 121 CASES MONITORED
AND CLOSED IN 2023. THE
INVESTIGATIONS THE INVESTIGATORS
PERFORMED POORLY IN NEARLY 64%
OF THOSE CASES. CDCR. RECEIVED
POOR RATINGS, PRIMARILY BECAUSE
ITS INVESTIGATORS CONDUCTED
BIASED INVESTIGATIONS, CONDUCTED
INCOMPLETE INVESTIGATIONS, USED
POOR INVESTIGATIVE TECHNIQUES,
AND FAILED TO ENSURE THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF
INVESTIGATIONS. OUT OF THE SAME
121 CASES, WE ALSO ASSESSED THE
PERFORMANCE OF WARDENS WHO MADE
DISCIPLINARY DETERMINATIONS IN
THOSE CASES AND FOUND THAT
WARDENS PERFORMED POORLY. ABOUT
50% OF THE TIME. WARDENS
RECEIVED POOR RATINGS BECAUSE
THEY MADE POOR FINDINGS AS TO
WHETHER MISCONDUCT OCCURRED,
DELAYED IN MAKING FINDINGS, OR
ENGAGED IN POOR RECORD KEEPING
IN THE DEPARTMENT'S STAFF
MISCONDUCT DATABASE. WE ALSO
ASSESSED 68 CASES THAT HAD CDCR
ATTORNEYS ASSIGNED TO THEM.
THOSE ATTORNEYS WERE RESPONSIBLE
FOR HANDLING A CASE, BEGINNING
WITH THE INVESTIGATION, ALL THE
WAY THROUGH TO THE CONCLUSION OF
ANY RESULTING EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS. WE
ASSESSED HOW WELL DEPARTMENT
ATTORNEYS PROVIDED LEGAL ADVICE
TO INVESTIGATORS AND TO WARDENS.
WE ALSO EVALUATED THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT
ATTORNEY IN LITIGATING EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. WE FOUND
THAT DEPARTMENT ATTORNEYS,
ATTORNEYS PERFORM POORLY IN 32
CASES, APPROXIMATELY 47% ON SOME
ISSUES WE IDENTIFIED WERE
ATTORNEYS PROVIDING POOR ADVICE
TO INVESTIGATORS DURING THE
INVESTIGATION AND TO WARDENS
REGARDING THOSE INVESTIGATIONS.
DISCIPLINARY FINDINGS, OR BOTH.
THEY FAIL TO ADVISE THE
INVESTIGATORS TO COLLECT
RELEVANT EVIDENCE, SUCH AS
MEDICAL DOCUMENTS OR VIDEO
RECORDINGS, OR INTERVIEW KEY
PERSONS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE ALLEGATION. OVERALL, IN OUR
2023 ANNUAL REPORT, WE
DETERMINED THE DEPARTMENT
PERFORMED SATISFACTORILY WHEN
MAKING SCREENING DECISIONS
POORLY AND COMPLETING INQUIRIES
AND POORLY IN CONDUCTING
INVESTIGATIONS AND IN THE
EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINE PROCESS.
TURNING BRIEFLY TO THE JANUARY
SPECIAL REPORT IN JULY OF LAST
YEAR, DURING THE COURSE OF OUR
MONITORING, WE RECEIVED A CDCR
MEMORANDUM OUTLINING A DIRECTIVE
TO CONVERT BACKLOG GRIEVANCES
CONTAINING ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INVESTIGATED BY THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS INTO ROUTINE
GRIEVANCES THAT WOULD BE
ADDRESSED BY LOCAL PRISON STAFF.
INSTEAD THE DIRECTIVE APPEARED
TO VIOLATE CDCR'S NEW
REGULATIONS, SO WE IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN LOOKING INTO IT. WE
LEARNED THAT BEGINNING IN
FEBRUARY OF 2022, CDCR BEGAN
DEVELOPING A BACKLOG OF OVER 900
GRIEVANCES THAT THE CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM IDENTIFIED AS
CONTAINING ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. THE GRIEVANCES THAT
HAD BEEN REFERRED TO THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR AN
ALLEGATION, INQUIRY OR
INVESTIGATION HAD NOT YET BEEN
PROCESSED. AS A RESULT OF THE
DIRECTIVE, CDCR WOUND UP CLOSING
595 CASES CONTAINING ALLEGATIONS
OF STAFF MISCONDUCT,
RECLASSIFYING THEM AS ROUTINE
GRIEVANCES AND REDIRECTING THEM
TO THE PRISON GRIEVANCE OFFICES
TO BE OPENED AS NEW ROUTINE
GRIEVANCES. BEING MINDFUL OF
TIME, I WILL QUICKLY HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF OUR FINDINGS. FIRST WAS
THAT CDCR ALLOWED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS TO TAKE DISCIPLINARY
ACTION TO EXPIRE IN MANY OF THE
GRIEVANCES BEFORE THEY WERE
REDIRECTED, STATE LAW GENERALLY
REQUIRES THAT DISCIPLINE AGAINST
PEACE OFFICERS OCCUR WITHIN ONE
YEAR OF DISCOVERY OF THE ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT IN THREE YEARS FOR
ALL OTHER STAFF, WE FOUND THAT
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
EXPIRED IN 127 OF THOSE CASES
BEFORE CDCR EVEN BEGAN
REDIRECTING THEM BACK TO THE
PRISONS. AS A RESULT, CDCR WAS
POWERLESS TO DISCIPLINE STAFF IF
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
WERE FOUND TO HAVE OCCURRED. 129
OF THE GRIEVANCES WERE SENT BACK
WITHIN 60 DAYS OF THE STATUTE
EXPIRING, WHICH GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT A VERY SHORT TIME TO
REVIEW, INVESTIGATE AND HOLD
STAFF ACCOUNTABLE. WE ALSO FOUND
THAT A SECOND FINDING WAS IN 71
OF THE 595 GRIEVANCES. CDCR
CLOSED AND RECLASSIFIED THEM AS
ROUTINE, AND WE FOUND THAT IN
EACH OF THOSE, AT LEAST ONE,
THERE WAS ONE ALLEGATION OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT AND STAFF
MISCONDUCT, WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
A COMPLEX ISSUE REQUIRING
SPECIALIZED INVESTIGATIVE SKILLS
TO BE INVESTIGATED, SUCH AS
RETALIATION, DISCRIMINATION, AND
DISHONESTY. THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO BE REFERRED TO THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS. ALLEGATIONS
INVESTIGATION UNIT. WE FOUND
THAT AT LEAST 16 OF THOSE 71
CASES WERE NOT WERE NOT EVEN
INVESTIGATED BY LOCALLY
DESIGNATED INVESTIGATORS, WHO
MOST LIKELY DID NOT RECEIVE THAT
SPECIALIZED SKILL IN CONDUCTING
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS. A THIRD
FINDING WAS THAT WE FOUND THAT
THESE CASES WERE NOT BEING,
TIMELY INVESTIGATED. REGULATIONS
. GENERALLY REQUIRE THAT THESE
ALLEGATIONS BE COMPLETED WITHIN
60 DAYS. OF THE 71 THAT WE HAD
SPECIFICALLY REVIEWED, WE
DETERMINED CDCR TOOK AN AVERAGE
OF 346 DAYS FROM THE DATE IT
FIRST RECEIVED THE CLAIM TO
CLOSE THE GRIEVANCES. THE
DEPARTMENT'S TOTAL PROCESSING
TIME IN 71 OF THE CASE FILES WE
REVIEWED RANGED BETWEEN 214 TO
548 DAYS, AND IT TOOK MORE THAN
A YEAR TO CLOSE 28 OF THE 71
CASES WE REVIEWED. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I'LL
LET YOU CLOSE. YES, YES. SO
FINALLY, WE WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT THAT THIS SPECIAL REVIEW
LOOKED AT ONE DECISION THAT WE
FOUND WAS PROBLEMATIC WHEN
DETERMINING HOW TO ADDRESS A
BACKLOG OF GRIEVANCES AND THAT
WAS AMASSED UNDER THIS PROCESS.
ONCE AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, I'M
GOING TO MOVE OVER TO
COLLEAGUES. OH, SORRY. LET ME DO
THIS, CHRIS CHAMBERS, DIRECTOR
OF DIVISION OF INTERNAL
OVERSIGHT AND RESEARCH OF CDCR,
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND.
THANK YOU. AND GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CHRIS
CHAMBERS, AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF CDCR'S DIVISION OF
CORRECTIONAL POLICY RESEARCH AND
INTERNAL OVERSIGHT. MY DIVISION
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY ASPECTS
OF INTERNAL OVERSIGHT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT, INCLUDING
INVESTIGATIONS OF STAFF.
MISCONDUCT IS NOTED IN THE
AGENDA AND IN THE TESTIMONY OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. CDCR HAS RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS FROM
RECENT BUDGET ACTS TO ADDRESS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
WE WANT TO THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR RECOGNIZING THE GRAVENESS OF
THIS ISSUE AND WORKING WITH BOTH
CDCR AND THE OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL ON ESTABLISHING AND
IMPROVING PROCESSES, AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THESE
EFFORTS WITH RESPECT TO THE
OAG'S RECENT REPORT PUBLISHED ON
APRIL 25TH, THE REPORT OUTLINES
A NUMBER OF FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CDCR IS
CURRENTLY REVIEWING AND
ASSESSING FOR POTENTIAL
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PROCESS. WE
RECOGNIZE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED WITHIN THIS REPORT.
WHILE CDCR UNDERSTANDS THAT
THERE IS MORE TO WORK TO BE
DONE, THE DEPARTMENT REMAINS
COMMITTED TO BE PROACTIVE AND
REFINING THESE PROCESSES. CDCR
APPRECIATES THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S MONITORING
AND FEEDBACK. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP AND
OPEN COMMUNICATION ON THESE VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND BRINGING ON
MEANINGFUL CHANGE. AS PART OF
THESE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS, WE
NOTE CDCR CONTINUES TO REGULARLY
ASSESS OUR NEEDS AND ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE SUFFICIENT AND
EFFICIENTLY ALLOCATED RESOURCES
SO THAT ALL COMPLAINTS ARE
HANDLED APPROPRIATELY. I WOULD
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
IMPROVEMENTS ALREADY MADE WITH
RESPECT TO TRAINING OF STAFF,
BOTH ON THE INVESTIGATOR SIDE TO
IMPROVE OUR PERFORMANCE, AS WELL
AS ON THE LOCAL RESOURCES OR
LOCAL DESIGNATED INVESTIGATORS,
LATE LAST YEAR, WE STARTED TO
INCREASE THE FREQUENCY OF
TRAINING PROVIDED TO THESE LOCAL
DESIGNATED INVESTIGATORS AS WELL
AS WE STARTED A BIWEEKLY
MEETING, A CALL THAT THESE
LADIES COULD JOIN AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THEY MAY HAVE
WITH OUR SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS.
STILL, THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO IN AND
ADDRESS CHAU, THE JANUARY OIG
REPORT. ALTHOUGH CDCR HAS SOME
DIFFERENCES IN OPINION
CONCERNING THE JANUARY OIG
REPORT AND SUBSEQUENT
CONVERSION, OF THE REMAINING 595
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION
MANAGEMENT SECTION INQUIRIES,
CDCR DID MAKE THE DIFFICULT
DECISION TO REDIRECT SOME
INQUIRIES THAT ALLEGE STAFF
MISCONDUCT SUBMITTED UNDER
CDCR'S OLD PROCESS BACK TO
INSTITUTIONS OFFICES OF
GRIEVANCE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT LED TO
THIS DECISION, I'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT. WHEN THE
ALLEGATION INQUIRY MANAGEMENT
SECTION, OR AMES AS IT'S KNOWN
OR WAS KNOWN, WAS INITIATED IN
MARCH OF 2020 AND CONDUCTED
INQUIRIES SUFFICIENT TO EITHER
DEFINITIVELY REFUTE THE
ALLEGATION, AT WHICH POINT THE
CASES WERE SUBMITTED TO THE
INSTITUTION'S OFFICE OF
GRIEVANCE OR RESPONSE, OR
DETERMINE IF THERE WAS
REASONABLE BELIEF MISCONDUCT
OCCURRED. IF THAT REASONABLE
BELIEF WAS FOUND, THE INQUIRY
STOPPED IN THE MATTER WAS
RETURNED TO THE HIRING
AUTHORITY. GENERALLY, THE
INSTITUTIONS WARDEN, WHO THEN
DETERMINED WHETHER TO SUBMIT A
MATTER TO INTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
FORMAL REVIEW AND, IF
APPROPRIATE, FOR INVESTIGATION.
THÀNH. IN EARLY 2022, CDCR
IMPLEMENTED AN IMPROVED STAFF
MISCONDUCT PROCESS TO ENSURE THE
PROPER IDENTIFICATION AND
HANDLING OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
ALLEGATIONS. THIS WAS DONE UNDER
COURT ORDER AND IN PART, WITH A
STIPULATED AGREEMENT WITH
ARMSTRONG PLAINTIFFS. CDCR HAD A
PHASED IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
PROCESS, AND IN JANUARY OF 2022,
THE CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM,
THE CENTRALIZED OIA UNIT THAT
SCREENS ALL ALLEGATIONS, WAS
FIRST ACTIVATE BECAUSE THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT
WAS YET TO BE STOOD UP. THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM
CONTINUED TO ROUTE MATTERS TO
THE ALLEGATION INQUIRY
MANAGEMENT SECTION ON TOP OF
ALREADY EXISTING WORKLOAD, WHICH
OVERWHELMED THAT SYSTEM.
STARTING ON MAY 31ST OF 2022,
CASES IDENTIFIED BY CENTRALIZED
SCREENING TEAM IS CONTAINED
CONTAINING CERTAIN SPECIFIED
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
INCLUDED ON THE ALLEGATION
DECISION INDEX. WERE WERE FOR
SIX PERSONS COVERED UNDER COURT
ORDERS, AND THE ARMSTRONG CLASS
ACTION WERE REFERRED TO THE
ALLEGATION INVESTIGATION UNIT
FOR THOROUGH INVESTIGATION. THE
RESULTS OF THESE INVESTIGATIONS
WERE PROVIDED TO THE HIRING
AUTHORITY. WHO DETERMINES
WHETHER, BASED UPON THE
INVESTIGATION, THERE IS STAFF
MISCONDUCT? AND IF SO, WHAT
LEVEL OF DISCIPLINE TO IMPOSE
ALLEGATIONS SCREENED BY THE
CENTRALIZED SCREENING TEAM AND
WHICH FOR STAFF MISCONDUCT WAS
IDENTIFIED FOR ALL OTHER
INSTITUTIONS, AND PAROLE REGIONS
CONTINUE TO ROUTE TO THE
ALLEGATION. INQUIRY MANAGEMENT
SECTION FOR INQUIRY. THANK YOU.
DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE? I WILL DO
SO VERY QUICKLY, IN PLAIN, IN
PLAIN TERMS, FOLKS, WITH THIS,
THIS MEANS IS WE WERE RUNNING A
BIFURCATED PROCESS, WHILE WE'RE
INCREMENTALLY, INCREMENTALLY
STANDING UP OUR IU UNIT IN
WINDING DOWN INQUIRIES AT THE
TIME, WE HAD, I BELIEVE IT'S
2500 CASES THAT WERE OPENED IN
AMES. WE HAD 3500 CASES THAT
WERE OPEN IN IU, AND THE STAFF
WAS BOUNCING BETWEEN THEM. WE
WERE PROJECTED TO HAVE A 7000
CASE BACKLOG, BY THE JUNE OF
THIS YEAR, WE WERE ALREADY
LOSING CASES AS MENTIONED BY
INSPECTOR GENERAL SINGH, TO
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS. TO PUT
SIMPLY, THE SYSTEM WAS BREAKING
UNDER ITS OWN WEIGHT. WE HAD TO
MAKE A CRITICAL DECISION TO PUT
EFFORTS TOWARDS THOSE SERIOUS,
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE ALLEGATION
INVESTIGATION UNIT, THE THOUGHT
BEING, IT'S BETTER TO HAVE
SOMEONE LOOK AT EACH MATTER THAN
TO HAVE MATTERS THAT WOULD BE
LOST TO STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS,
WHICH WE WERE ALREADY LOSING.
I'M HAPPY TO SAY AT THIS POINT
THAT ALTHOUGH THAT WAS A
DIFFICULT DECISION, WE HAVE LOST
NO FURTHER CASES TO SOL. SINCE
THEN. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CONCENTRATE OUR TEAMS, TO
CONCENTRATE ON THOSE MOST
SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS AND INSTEAD
OF HAVING OVER 3500, WE'RE NOW
DOWN TO 20 UNDER 2500 CASES, WE
DESPITE REGULATORY CHANGES IN
NUMEROUS BUSINESS PROCESS
ADJUSTMENTS, THE PROCESS STILL
RESULTS IN VOLUMES OF COMPLAINTS
BEING INVESTIGATED THAT DO NOT
WARRANT INVESTIGATION. THANK YOU
, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO DO
WE HAVE ANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SENATOR SARAH? SOUND LIKE YOU
JUST STARTED TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT I WAS. I WAS GOING
TO ASK HERE, OF THESE
ALLEGATIONS, WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM? DO WE NOT HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO PROCESS OR ARE WE
BEING INUNDATED WITH TRIVIAL
PROCESS OR TRIVIAL COMPLAINTS?
AND IN OTHER WORDS, HOW MUCH IS
TRIVIAL AND HOW MUCH IS SERIOUS
ALLEGATION? THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION, AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT, SENATOR, AS WAS POINTED
OUT, WE RECEIVE 183,000
ALLEGATIONS, OF WHICH 20,000
WERE THOUGHT TO CONTAIN STAFF
MISCONDUCT. WHEN WE LOOK AT
THEM, WE HAVE CASES, FOR
EXAMPLE, SIR, THAT HAVE COME IN
WHERE, A COOK WAS NOT WEARING
GLOVES AND THAT MATTER HAS TO BE
SUBMITTED TO OIA FOR
INVESTIGATION. TO PUT SIMPLY, I
THINK THE INTENDED PROCESS AND
THE INTENDED SCOPE OF THE
ALLEGATION DECISION INDEX IS NOT
BEING MET BECAUSE THE
DEFINITIONS JUST TOO BROAD. AND
WHAT HAPPENS IS WE INUNDATE OUR
PROCESSES AND WE END UP HAVING
THIS BACKLOG. IT BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE WHAT THE DIRECTIVE
WAS, IS TO GET A HANDLE ON ALL
OF THESE COMPLAINTS, BUT THEY
ALL GOT BATCHED TOGETHER AND THE
DIRECTIVE SHOULD BE NARROWED
DOWN TO VERY SERIOUS COMPLAINTS
AND A PROCESS FOR THAT. AND THEN
A DIFFERENT ONE FOR THE MINOR
COMPLAINTS, YOU KNOW, THEY
ROLLED THEIR EYES AT ME OR
WHATEVER IT IS, THOSE KIND OF
COMPLAINTS WOULD GO IN A
DIFFERENT WOULD THAT BE HELPFUL
IF WE HAD THOSE KIND OF
DIRECTIVES? YES, SIR. AND I WILL
ADD THAT WE ARE WORKING RIGHT
NOW WITH ARMSTRONG AND COURT
EXPERT TO LOOK AT SOME SERIOUS
CHANGES TO THE STAFF MISCONDUCT
PROCESS RIGHT NOW, WE'RE
IDENTIFYING ITEMS THAT THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY MODIFY THIS
SYSTEM TO MAKE IT MORE
SUSTAINABLE, AND MAKE US BE ABLE
TO, AGAIN, CONCENTRATE ON THOSE
CASES THAT THAT WE KNOW. I THINK
THERE ARE SEVERAL WITHIN YOUR
AGENDA. THESE ARE CASES THAT WE
MUST LOOK AT. WE MUST GIVE THEM
ADEQUATE ATTENTION. I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE WANT OUR MONEY
SPENT IS ON THE SERIOUS CASES
AND, AND, IS AS FAR AS GOING
FORWARD, HAVING THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO
THOSE. IF WE WERE ABLE TO
SEPARATE THOSE TWO OUT, WOULD
YOU BE ABLE TO DO THE OTHER
PART? A LOT MORE EFFICIENTLY?
OKAY. THANK YOU. CAN I ASK
AREN'T THOSE ALREADY SEPARATED
OUT? YES, THOSE CASES ARE
ALREADY SEPARATED OUT. SO YOU
HAVE 120,000 COMPLAINTS,
CORRECT? YES. 20,000 BEING STAFF
MISCONDUCT AT THE LOWER END.
IT'S ALREADY TIERED OUT. I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT TO A
DEGREE, MA'AM. SO SOME OF THOSE
SOME OF THOSE CASES ARE STILL
FINDING THEIR WAY TO
INVESTIGATORS FOR FULL
INVESTIGATION THAT WE FEEL ARE
SHOULD NOT BE. AND THAT'S BASED
UPON THE ALLEGATION DECISION
INDEX THAT WE DID AGREE TO WITH
THE COURT. OKAY. AND I'M GOING
TO MOVE ON TO SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU, THE PART THAT'S MOST
DISTURBING, AND I KNOW YOU WENT
REALLY FAST MISSING, BUT BUT
POORLY, POORLY, POORLY, POORLY.
THAT'S ALL I HEARD COMING OUT IN
TERMS OF THE, THE, YOU KNOW, THE
TIME THAT YOU PUT INTO IT AND
YOU SAID CASE AFTER CASE, NOT
CASE AFTER CASE, BUT ISSUE AFTER
ISSUE AFTER ISSUE WAS POOR, 68%
HANDLED POORLY, 88% HANDLED
POORLY, 64% HANDLED POORLY.
CONFIDENTIALITY ISSUES HANDLED
POORLY. THE DEPARTMENT ATTORNEYS
DID NOT ADEQUATELY ADVISE
INVESTIGATORS. I MEAN, THAT'S
THAT'S TO THINK THAT AREA AFTER
AREA AFTER AREA IS SO HIGHLY
SUCH A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
HANDLED POORLY. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS THIS YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND I'M HEARING
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'VE HEARD
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. YOU GOT
RESOURCES. WHAT IS GOING ON
HERE. AND WE CAN'T KEEP COMING
BACK AND HEARING THE SAME THING,
THERE IS A THERE WAS A ISSUE OF
THE INDEPENDENT SUFFICIENT
INDEPENDENCE WHEN A, A COMPLAINT
OR A GRIEVANCE WAS FILED, WE
NEEDED THE THEY NEEDED TO KNOW
THAT THEY HAD THE
CONFIDENTIALITY K¾T THEY HAD THE
A REAL INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION
OR CONSIDERATION, I MEAN,
THERE'S JUST ISSUE AFTER ISSUE,
I'M JUST SO SHOCKED BY HEARING
THIS. WHAT WHAT'S GOING ON? WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT THIS?
WHAT ARE WE SERIOUSLY GOING TO
DO ABOUT THIS? WE BELIEVE
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. OIG COURT EXPERT,
AS WELL AS ARMSTRONG ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. WE AGAIN,
THE VOLUME, THE SHEER VOLUME
THAT'S COMING IN, OUR
INVESTIGATORS ARE CARRYING WELL
OVER 25 CASES AT ANY TIME.
THAT'S FAR TOO MANY TO ACTIVELY
WORK AND PAY THE PROPER
ATTENTION TO. WE AGREE THAT
THERE IS A NEED FOR MORE IN
DEPTH, MORE TIME, BETTER
TRAINING FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO KEEP UP.
THAT'S NOT AN EXCUSE, IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE TO MAKE CHANGES ON AGAIN,
MEANINGFUL CHANGES TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK. THE INTENT OF THIS
SYSTEM WAS TO LOOK AT, AGAIN,
THESE AS, ALLEGATIONS IN REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE BEING
HANDLED PROPERLY AND THAT
THERE'S A LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THAT. JUST
QUICKLY. YES, I DO AGREE. A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT WE SAW,
THERE WERE POOR PERFORMANCES, WE
MAKE REASONABLE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE DEPARTMENT. EVERY SECTION
OF THE REPORT THAT WE PUBLISHED
DOES HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HELP THE DEPARTMENT IMPROVE, TO
HELP CDCR IMPROVE IN THE AREAS
WHERE WE SEE THEY'RE NOT MEETING
THE MARK. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEWMAN, I JUST WANT TO
ADD MY VOICE. SENATOR DURAZO
ASKED MY QUESTION FOR ME. AND AS
I RECALL, WE HAD A HEARING ON
THIS LAST YEAR. YEAR BEFORE. AND
AT THAT TIME, I REMEMBER ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WAS DISCUSSED
WAS THE QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT, COMPLAINTS THAT WERE
SERIOUS IN NATURE, SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT STAFF MISCONDUCT, WERE
APPARENTLY BEING EITHER,
MISDIRECTED OR WILLFULLY
IGNORED, AND IT DOES SOUND LIKE
WE HAVEN'T MADE THE PROGRESS
THAT WE HAD HOPED COMING OUT OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. AGAIN, IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN TWO YEARS AGO
WHEN SENATOR D'ORAZIO WAS CHAIR.
SO I YOU KNOW, I'D ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER IF, EITHER WE HAVEN'T
GIVEN YOU THE RESOURCES OR THE
ORIGINAL APPROACH IS NOT
WORKING, MAYBE WE SHOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY RETHINK THAT
APPROACH TO GET AT THE REAL
GOAL, WHICH IS TO SEPARATE THE
TRIVIAL FROM THE IMPORTANT AND
MAKE SURE THAT STAFF MISCONDUCT
COMPLAINTS, WHEN VALIDATED, ARE
PROPERLY PURSUED, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO RESPOND, BUT I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE THINGS, I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU. THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS, THE
OFFICERS THAT WORK IN THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS IS THE WAY
THAT THE OPERATION IS, IS THAT
OFFICERS ROTATE OUT? NO, MA'AM.
THESE ARE OFFICERS OR THESE ARE
INVESTIGATORS THAT ARE HIRED IN,
THEY ARE IN ONE OF THREE
REGIONS, EITHER OUR SOUTHERN OR
CENTRAL OR OUR NORTHERN REGION,
AND THEY COME IN AND WE TRAIN
THEM AND THEY STAY UNTIL THEY
EITHER GET ANOTHER JOB OR
RETIRE. OKAY. AND THESE ARE
FORMER OFFICERS AS WELL, THAT IS
CORRECT. OKAY. AND, IS THERE SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, AND I'M GOING TO
CONTINUE TO RELATE IT BACK TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND POLICE
DEPARTMENTS HAVE AN OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS OR DEPARTMENT
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND THEY
KEEP ROTATING OFFICERS THAT WERE
ON DUTY ON, YOU KNOW, IN THE
STREETS, KIND OF ROTATING AND
LEARNING THAT. I DO THINK THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC, BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
EVERY SINGLE OFFICER WILL THEN
KNOW, YOU KNOW, HOW AN
INVESTIGATION IS TAKEN, INTO
ACCOUNT. AND, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
MORE PEOPLE INVOLVED AND THERE'S
A CULTURE OF, YOU KNOW, IT'S US
VERSUS THEM. AND IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM IN PARTICULAR, IT'S
INMATES VERSUS COPS. LET'S BE
HONEST ABOUT THAT. RIGHT, THERE
IS A POWER DYNAMICS AT PLAY, AND
I UNDERSTAND AND I AND I WANT TO
TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY BECAUSE
THIS IS OF CONCERN TO ME. THE
LARGER COMMUNITY AND SOCIETY
OFTEN FORGET ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN PRISON
AND SERVING TIME, AND OFTEN VIEW
THEM IN A NEGATIVE WAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN PRISON FOR A REASON,
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME,
THEY'RE HUMAN BEINGS, RIGHT? AND
AND, YOU KNOW, PERSONALLY, I
DON'T EVEN LIKE PUTTING MY DOG
IN A CRATE ALL DAY. I REALLY
DON'T LIKE THAT. AND THERE'S
SIGNIFICANT ISSUES THAT TAKE
PLACE. AND WHEN THERE IS A POWER
DYNAMICS AND WE'RE SEEING
COMPLAINTS 120,000 COMPLAINTS IN
A SINGLE YEAR, THAT'S
CONCERNING. AND IF IT'S AS
SIMPLE, SIMPLE AS NOT WEARING A
GLOVE IN THE KITCHEN, THERE
SHOULD BE HIGH STANDARDS,
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THAT WE
HAVE A SHRINKING PRISON
POPULATION AND A GROWING BUDGET.
IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE. AND WE
CONTINUE IN ONE YEAR, 120,000
COMPLAINTS, WHETHER OR SMALL
COMPLAINTS OR BIG COMPLAINTS,
THAT'S A PROBLEM. 20,000
VERIFIED MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS.
RIGHT STAFF MISCONDUCT. YOU
KNOW, EACH OF THESE EMPLOYEES IS
ARE PAID BY THE STATE. THEY HAVE
A DUTY AND A RESPONSIBILITY, AND
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
INMATES THAT THEY OVERSEE. MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE OIG RECOMMENDS THIS
AND THAT. AND YET THEY MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN 2022 THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED. AND
CONSISTENTLY, I HEAR THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS
. CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT? IT'S
VERY CLEAR THE DATA HAS BEEN
ANALYZED NOW IT'S ACTIONS TO
IMPLEMENT. AND WE'RE NOT SEEING
IMPLEMENTATION THÀNH. RIGHT. IT
DOES NOT JUSTIFY MORE INPUT. AND
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND, WE HAVE
SEVERAL HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS THAT
INVESTIGATE THESE THESE
PARTICULAR COMPLAINTS FULL TIME,
WITH A CASELOAD OF ABOUT 25
COMPLAINTS AT A TIME. RIGHT.
THAT'S YOUR WORDS, RIGHT, AND I
COMPARE THAT TO SOCIAL WORKERS
WHO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
INVESTIGATING CHILDREN, YOU
KNOW, ABUSES AND MUCH MORE. AND
I WANT TO SAY THAT THE FACT THAT
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS RUNS
OUT AS SOME LOOPHOLE OF LIKE,
HOW WE CAN GET AWAY WITH CERTAIN
THINGS AND HOW WE CAN PROTECT
THINGS. AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
WANT TO PUSH BACK, RIGHT? BUT I
WANT TO SAY THAT THE LARGER
PUBLIC, AS MUCH AS WE WANT TO
OBVIOUSLY HOLD BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE IN SOCIETY, WE ALSO
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
AND WE HAVE INVESTED IN IS ALSO
HELD TO A HIGHER STANDARD,
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
HUMAN LIVES ARE STILL AT STAKE
HERE TOO, RIGHT? AND NOT EVERY
SINGLE PERSON THAT'S SERVING A
PRISON TIME IS A SERIAL KILLER
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT, RIGHT?
SO WHEN WE COMPARE OURSELVES AS
A NATION AND AS A STATE TO OTHER
COUNTRIES OF HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND MUCH MORE, AND WE
CAN TALK ABOUT ALL OF THAT
FUNDAMENTAL Kò WE ALSO HAVE TO
HAVE HIGHER STANDARDS FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WE TRUST WITH THE
CARE OF THESE INMATES. RIGHT.
AND I'M GOING TO BE HONEST, I
AND YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
RESPOND. THERE IS A NUMBER OF
OIG RECOMMENDATIONS IN EVERY
SINGLE CATEGORY, RIGHT? WHETHER
IT'S HOW WE MONITOR THIS, YOU
KNOW, THE LOCAL INQUIRIES, THE
ALLEGATIONS, THE DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS, WHICH I HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYTHING OF. RIGHT. AS TO THIS
IS HOW WE HAVE DISCIPLINED THIS
MANY PEOPLE. THIS IS HOW MANY
CASES WE'VE CLOSED. THIS IS
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO BAD ACTORS.
AND THIS HARMS THE REPUTATION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AS A WHOLE. THAT
IS MY CONCERN. I FULLY SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IT'S HOW ARE WE GOING TO
CHANGE THE IMAGE AND THE CONCERN
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS THAT THAT IS
REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO PUSHING BACK OR STALLING OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IS NOT WORTH
IT. WE HAVE TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF
THESE CHANGES, ESPECIALLY ON THE
ONES THAT ARE MORE EGREGIOUS.
PEOPLE CANNOT DIE IN PRISONS
UNDER OUR WATCH. WE CANNOT KEEP
SAYING, OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE MORE SURVEILLANCE, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE MORE. THIS MORE
THIS, MORE THAT WHEN PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO BE VIOLATED AND
HARMED AND SO FORTH, INCLUDE
RAPES IN THE WOMEN'S PRISONS,
LET ALONE THE MEN'S PRISONS.
RIGHT. SO I REALLY JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT I'M HOPING THAT A LOT
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE
GOOD FAITH ACTIONS WE UNDERSTAND
AS LAYMEN THAT ARE NOT OFFICERS,
THAT THERE ARE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT, YOU KNOW,
THINGS HAPPEN AND, YOU KNOW,
IT'S SPLIT SECOND DECISIONS. I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT. AND
I, I THINK MOST OF US HAVE SOME
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION FOR THOSE
SITUATIONS. BUT THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO, WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT.
SO IT'S MORE OF A DIRECTION
RIGHT NOW THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE SIGNIFICANT IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS. NO
MORE TALK, JUST ACTUALLY DO IT.
YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM. ISSUE
NUMBER 32. SEXUAL ASSAULT
RESPONSE AND PREVENTION. WORKING
GROUP AND REPORT UPDATE.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO FIRST
HEAR FROM ANGELA KENT, ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF FEMALE OFFENDER
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES AT CDCR.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M ANGELA KENT,
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR FOR THE
WOMEN'S MISSION AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT RESPONSE AND
PREVENTION AND THE REPORT THE
CDCR PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE 2023 BUDGET ACT,
PROVIDED THE DEPARTMENT WITH A
ONE TIME ALLOCATION OF $250,000
TO FORM A WORKING GROUP
CONSISTING OF LEADERSHIP AND
STAFF FROM THE DEPARTMENT,
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LED BY FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE, INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
SURVIVED SEXUAL ASSAULT IN
CUSTODY, AND REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE SISTER WARRIORS
COALITION. THIS GROUP WAS TASKED
TO DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS AND
PRODUCE A REPORT PROVIDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND THE
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP. OUR
CURRENT LEADERSHIP TEAM IS FULLY
COMMITTED TO EXCUSE ME TO
PROTECTING VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND ENSURING AVENUES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR BOTH THE
INCARCERATED, INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND STAFF TO SAFELY
REPORT MISCONDUCT. WE HAVE ZERO
TOLERANCE FOR SEXUAL ABUSE AND
HARASSMENT FOR THOSE UNDER OUR
CARE. IT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WOMEN
INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS ARE OFTEN VICTIMS
OF PAST TRAUMA, AND INCLUDING
SEXUAL ASSAULT. OUR APPROACH IS
A TRAUMA INFORMED ORGANIZATION
AND ADDRESSING SEXUAL ABUSE AND
TRAUMA, AS WELL AS THE RESOURCES
THAT WE OFFER, ARE CRITICAL TO
BEING RESPONSIVE TO THEIR
TRAUMA. THE DEPARTMENT IS
UNDERTAKING A NUMBER OF EFFORTS
TO RESPOND TO THE ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT AND INVESTIGATIONS OF
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT ARE INVESTIGATED BY
STAFF OUTSIDE OF THE
INSTITUTIONS AND CAN BE REVIEWED
BY THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. THESE EFFORTS INCLUDE
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL RAPE
CRISIS CENTERS TO ENSURE VICTIM
ADVOCATES ARE AVAILABLE NOT JUST
DURING THE INVESTIGATIVE
PROCESS, BUT FROM THE REPORTING
ON, AS WELL AS DEDICATED PHONE
LINES TO CONNECT INDIVIDUALS TO
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT RESOURCES. AS
WE ARE EXPANDING OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO ENHANCE
EDUCATION AND RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THE INCARCERATED
WOMEN TO INCLUDE PREA REPORTING
AND INVESTIGATIVE PROCESSES, WE,
THE LEADERSHIP AND THE WOMEN'S
COMMISSION, CONDUCT REGULAR
MEETINGS WITH THE INCARCERATED
WOMEN AS WELL AS INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS. EXCUSE ME
. WE ARE ALSO WORKING TO DEVELOP
AND EXPAND OUR MENTORSHIP. PEER
MENTORSHIP. PEER EDUCATION AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE SISTER
WARRIORS FREEDOM COALITION. WE
ACTIVELY WORK TO ESTABLISH THE
SISTER WARRIORS AMBASSADOR
PROGRAM AND THE WOMEN'S
INSTITUTION, AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR CONTINUED WORK WITH THEM.
WE ARE ACTIVELY WORKING TO
ESTABLISH FULL TIME PREA
COORDINATORS AND OUR WOMEN'S
INSTITUTIONS. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT IS CONTINUING TO
IMPLEMENT AND REFINE
ACCOUNTABILITY INVESTIGATIVE
MEASURES, UTILIZATION OF BODY
CAMERAS AT BOTH WOMEN'S
INSTITUTIONS, GAINING COMPLIANCE
WITH DEPARTMENTAL POLICIES AS
THE DEPARTMENT TAKES SERIOUSLY
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS FOR EXAMPLE, WE
MONITOR CASES FOR RETALIATION
FOR A MINIMUM OF 90 DAYS WHERE
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
OR SEXUAL VIOLENCE HAVE OCCURRED
. INCARCERATED PERSONS WHO
REPORT SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OR
ABUSE ARE PROVIDED. A VICTIM
ADVOCATE RESOURCE THROUGH THE
RAPE CRISIS CENTERS LOCALLY TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. WE CAN DO THE
TRAUMA EXPERIENCED BY OUR
INCARCERATED WOMEN WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
OUR INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER, I, MY
LEADERSHIP TEAM, ARE COMMITTED
TO BUILDING A SYSTEM OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO PREVENT VICTIMIZATION. I
BELIEVE THAT OUR COMMITMENT TO
BUILDING THIS AND STRENGTHENING
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS. AND
BUILDING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCORPORATES
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES AND EMPOWERING OUR
INCARCERATED WOMEN TO HAVE A
VOICE WILL BUILD TRUST AND
CREATE SAFETY IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS. THANK YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO EMERICH
SINGH, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
GOOD MORNING. AMRIK SINGH,
INSPECTOR GENERAL, AS THE SEXUAL
ABUSE IN DETENTION AND
ELIMINATION ACT OMBUDSPERSON, WE
PERFORM SEVERAL FUNCTIONS IN
THIS SPACE. WHEN WE RECEIVE
COMMUNICATION FROM AN
INCARCERATED PERSON, A FAMILY
MEMBER OR AN ADVOCATE THAT
INCLUDES INFORMATION ALLEGING A
PREVIOUS PERSON HAS OCCURRED. WE
NOTIFY THE WARDEN AT THE PRISON
WITH THIS INFORMATION, WHICH IS
MUCH INFORMATION AS WE CAN
SHARE, KEEPING IN MIND
CONFIDENTIALITY REQUESTS.
ALTHOUGH WE CANNOT INVESTIGATE
THESE ALLEGATIONS OURSELVES, WE
ARE REQUIRED TO FORWARD THESE
ALLEGATIONS TO CDCR IN
ACCORDANCE WITH FEDERAL PREA
REGULATIONS. WE HAVE TAKEN
EFFORTS TO PLACE POSTERS
THROUGHOUT EACH PRISON,
THROUGHOUT EACH FACILITY
INFORMING INCARCERATED PEOPLE
HOW THEY CAN NOTIFY US OF PREA
ALLEGATIONS. WE'VE ALSO
ESTABLISHED A QUICK DIAL NUMBER
SO THAT THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION CAN REPORT
INFORMATION TO US AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE WITH REGARDS TO THE
INCARCERATED PERSON, ALLEGATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN, REPORTED, IF
THEY HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
SEXUAL ABUSE OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BY A CDCR EMPLOYEE.
WE MONITOR MOST INVESTIGATIONS
THAT THE WARDENS REFER TO.
CDCR'S OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS, AND A SMALL PORTION OF
THE INVESTIGATION THAT ARE
PERFORMED FROM ALLEGATIONS THAT
COME THROUGH THE GRIEVANCE
PROCESS. IN THESE CASES, WE DO
EVALUATE HOW WELL CDCR
INVESTIGATES THOSE CASES AND
WHETHER OR NOT DISCIPLINE WAS
IMPLEMENTED APPROPRIATELY. AND
FINALLY, WE ALSO HAVE BEGUN A
SPECIAL REVIEW. THIS PAST MARCH
TO ASSESS CDCR'S PROCESS FOR
HANDLING ALLEGATIONS THAT AN
INCARCERATED PERSON WAS
SUBJECTED TO SEXUAL ABUSE OR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BY ANOTHER
INCARCERATED PERSON. THE SPECIAL
REVIEW WILL COVER A ONE YEAR
PERIOD AND WILL REVIEW THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMPLIANCE WITH
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES FOR PREA
INVESTIGATIONS AND DETERMINE IF
EACH PRISON'S INSTITUTIONAL PREA
REVIEW COMMITTEE PROPERLY
REVIEWED AND MADE APPROPRIATE
DETERMINATIONS IN THOSE CASES.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN OUR ROLE
AS THE OMBUDS PERSON, AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
. THANK YOU, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO AMIKA MOTA AND EMILY
WONDER FROM THE SISTER WARRIORS
FREEDOM COALITION. I DO WANT TO
SAY BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU GUYS,
YOU GUYS HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
THANK YOU. TO THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS AMIKA
MOTA. I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SISTER WARRIORS. WE
ARE HONORED TO HAVE BEEN
ENTRUSTED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
LEAD THE CONVENING OF THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT RESPONSE AND PREVENTION
WORKGROUP AND CRAFT THE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS MY COLLEAGUE
EMILY WILL PRESENT NEXT. THE
FUNDING PROVIDED TO SISTER
WARRIORS ALLOWED US TO DEDICATE
SIGNIFICANT STAFF TIME TO THE
WORKGROUP AND INCREASE OUR
PRESENCE IN BOTH WOMEN'S
DESIGNATED PRISONS, ADDING A
LAYER OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SUPPORT. THE FUNDING ALSO
RESOURCED OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
, SURVIVOR LED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ENGAGE IN AND LEAD THE WORK
TO END SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN
CARCERAL SETTINGS. OUR AIM WITH
THIS WORKGROUP WAS TO FOSTER
DIALOG AND COOPERATION BETWEEN
CDCR POLICY MAKERS AND THOSE
MOST IMPACTED BY THE PRISON
SYSTEM. THE MAIN DELIVERABLE HAS
BEEN A NEARLY 80 PAGE REPORT,
WHICH WE CREATED COLLABORATIVELY
WITH INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN'S
PRISONERS SURVIVED AND PUNISHED,
CALIFORNIA JUST DETENTION,
INTERNATIONAL, JUSTICE FIRST,
AND VALOR US. THE FOUNDATION OF
THIS REPORT IS THE FIRSTHAND
EXPERIENCES AND PERSPECTIVES OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY AND
CIW. OUR INSIGHTS DRAW FROM
WRITTEN CORRESPONDENCE, SMALL
GROUP DISCUSSIONS, AND TOWN
HALLS THAT WE HOSTED AT THE
PRISONS LAST FALL WHERE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE COULD
CONFIDENTIALLY SHARE THEIR
THOUGHTS AND EXPERIENCES WITH
CREDIBLE MESSENGERS. WE HAVE
MADE SOME PROGRESS SINCE WE
STARTED THIS COLLABORATION AT
THE TOWN HALLS THAT WE HOSTED.
27 BRAVE SURVIVORS TESTIFIED TO
THE ABUSE THAT THEY HAD SUFFERED
AT THE HANDS OF A GYNECOLOGIST
AT CIW FOR OVER A DECADE.
SHORTLY AFTER THOSE TOWN HALLS,
THIS DOCTOR WAS FINALLY REMOVED
FROM THE YARD. WE LAUNCHED AN
AMBASSADOR FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM,
WHICH AIMS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT IMPROVED METHODS OF
REPORTING SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
ACCESS TO TRAUMA SUPPORT,
INFORMED SUPPORT NETWORKS FOR
INCARCERATED SURVIVORS. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT NEWLY
CONFIRMED CDCR LEADERSHIP
SUPPORT ITS EFFORTS TO IMPROVE
CONDITIONS AND INCREASE
RESOURCES FOR SURVIVORS. THIS IS
A CRISIS THAT WILL NOT FIX
ITSELF. DESPITE THE EFFORTS OF
MANY NÓ CARCERAL SYSTEM HAS BEEN
ABLE TO ELIMINATE STAFF ABUSE.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT REPORT WHEN THE
ABUSERS HOLD THE KEYS TO OUR
CELLS. MEANWHILE, THE STATE'S
CARCERAL BUDGET CONTINUES TO
INCREASE WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE
ROOT CAUSES OF VIOLENCE INSIDE
THESE INSTITUTIONS. THE FOCUS OF
TRANSFORMATION WITHIN CALIFORNIA
PRISONS IS ON MEN'S PRISONS LIKE
SAN QUENTIN, WHERE WE SEE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT BY THE
STATE ON THE OTHER HAND, WOMEN'S
PRISONS ARE STILL DEALING WITH
AN ACT OF CRISIS. WE HAVE
OBSERVED THAT THOSE WOMEN'S
PRISONS MOSTLY RELY ON DONATIONS
FROM SMALL GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OUR OWN, TO
FUND REHABILITATIVE AND HEALING
EVENTS LIKE THE ONES MENTIONED
IN CDCR'S REPORT. THIS
DISCREPANCY IS SIGNIFICANT AND
CANNOT BE OVERLOOKED. WE URGE
CDCR, OUR LEGISLATORS, AND THE
GOVERNOR TO TAKE CONCRETE STEPS
TO END THE VIOLENCE IN OUR
PRISONS. SISTER WARRIORS AND OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING THIS
WORK. THANK YOU, COMMITTEE, FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TODAY. MY NAME
IS EMILY WUNDER. I'M THE
ADVOCACY DIRECTOR AT SISTER
WARRIORS AND THE PRIMARY
FACILITATOR OF THE WORKING GROUP
. OUR GROUP'S RECOMMENDATIONS
FELL INTO FIVE BROAD CATEGORIES.
THE FIRST CATEGORY ADDRESSES THE
SAFETY OF SURVIVORS OF THIS
ABUSE. WE RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
FEEDBACK THAT RELEASE OF
SURVIVORS TO THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IS THE ONLY TRUE
PATH TO SAFETY AND HEALING.
AFTER EXPERIENCING SEXUAL
VIOLENCE BY CDCR STAFF. NEXT, WE
ADDRESS SHIFTING THE CULTURE OF
CDCR FACILITIES AWAY FROM THE
VIOLENCE AND OPPRESSION THAT
ENABLES RAMPANT SEXUAL ABUSE. WE
RECOMMEND BETTER STAFF TRAINING
AND MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMMUNITY BUILDING INSIDE
PRISONS. WE ALSO RECOMMEND
CHANGES TO STANDARD PRACTICES
THAT ARE RETRAUMATIZING TO
INCARCERATED PEOPLE, A VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM HAVE PREVIOUSLY
EXPERIENCED SERIOUS ABUSE AND
TRAUMA. THESE PRACTICES INCLUDE
DENIAL OF ADEQUATE ACCESS TO
BASIC NEEDS, SEXUALIZING
ATTITUDES, AND A DISTURBING
TOLERANCE FOR PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE. THIRD,
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
INCARCERATED PEOPLE HAVE
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO SUPPORT
SERVICES, INCLUDING RAPE CRISIS
CENTERS, MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES,
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORTS. WE
RECOMMEND INCREASED FUNDING AND
COLLABORATION FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS. RAIMES INCARCERATED
PEOPLE SHOULD ALSO BE EMPOWERED
TO PROVIDE PEER SUPPORT. SISTER
WARRIORS IS ALREADY IMPLEMENTING
THESE TYPES OF SUPPORT THROUGH
OUR AMBASSADOR PROGRAM. NEXT, WE
ADDRESS THE FAILED REPORTING AND
INVESTIGATION PROCESS, WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN INCREDIBLY LOW
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM AND
CONSEQUENTLY IN LOW RATES OF
REPORTING. WE CALL FOR MORE
RIGOROUS AND SURVIVOR CENTERED
PRACTICES AS WELL AS EXTERNAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND OVERSIGHT,
INCLUDING GREATER INPUT FROM THE
OIG. FINALLY WE CALL FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY INADEQUATE AND
POORLY ENFORCED POLICIES AROUND
BODY WORN CAMERAS MEAN THAT
ABUSE OFTEN GOES UNREPORTED TO
PROTECT WHISTLEBLOWERS, WE
RECOMMEND OVERHAULING STRIP
SEARCH AND TRANSFER PRACTICES,
WHICH ARE OFTEN USED BOTH AS A
MEANS OF RETALIATION AS WELL AS
A PRIMARY FORM OF ABUSE, AND
FINALLY, WE RECOMMEND MECHANISMS
TO HOLD CDCR ACCOUNTABLE FOR
FAILING TO ADEQUATELY RESPOND TO
THAT CRISIS. THANK YOU,
COMMITTEE, FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THÀNH. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? SENATOR DURAZZO,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL OF
YOU AND ESPECIALLY TO OUR SISTER
WARRIORS FOR YOUR WORK, JUST A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. I WAS ON,
ONE ONE OF THE TRIPS TO THE
CHOWCHILLA FACILITY AND WE, YOU
KNOW, HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY OF
SEVERAL PEOPLE ON, ON THE PANEL.
I DON'T REMEMBER IF IT WAS THIS
ONE, OR ANOTHER DIFFERENT VISIT,
BUT I HAVE HEARD ABOUT
INCARCERATED WHISTLEBLOWERS
BEING HOUSED IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. DURING,
INVESTIGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT. HAVE YOU HEARD THAT
OR WHERE DOES IT FALL IN IN
TERMS OF OR RECOMMENDATION ON
HOW TO HANDLE THAT? I AND I
THINK IT WAS THE WOMAN WAS PUT
INTO SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. AND I
THINK ONE RESPONSE WAS, WELL, IT
WAS FOR HER OWN PROTECTION,
WHICH SEEMS REALLY WARPED. BUT,
THAT HAS BEEN STANDARD PRACTICE
PREVIOUSLY, CDCR DURING THIS
TIME FRAME OF COLLABORATING WITH
US ON ENDING SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN
THE PRISONS, HAS BEGUN TO SHARE
SOME OF THE DATA WITH US ABOUT
THE RESTRICTIVE HOUSING UNIT
WHO'S HOUSED THERE AND WHY, SO
WE DO FEEL ENCOURAGED BY SOME OF
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE SEEN,
ALTHOUGH WE ARE ALSO HEARING
FROM PEOPLE THAT ARE CURRENTLY
THERE, JUST A FEW DAYS AGO, THAT
ARE STILL HOUSED IN RESTRICTIVE
HOUSING UNIT, WHEN THEY'RE CLAIM
IS UNDER INVESTIGATION, SO IT
HAS BEEN A PRACTICE OF CDCR'S.
IT TYPICALLY IS STATED THAT THAT
IS TO PROTECT THE VICTIM, BUT WE
SEE IT TO BE FURTHER
TRAUMATIZING. AND SOME PEOPLE
FEAR REPORTING TERRIBLY, EVEN
MORE SO BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THEY'LL BE REMOVED FROM THEIR
ONLY SUPPORT SYSTEMS ON THE YARD
PROPERTY TAKEN AWAY, NOT ALLOWED
TO HAVE VISITS, PHONE CALLS,
THINGS LIKE THAT. CAN I ADD?
YEAH. THANK YOU. WE'VE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH FOLKS AROUND
THIS AND, IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT FACILITIES ARE TRYING TO
MOVE AWAY FROM THIS, BUT IT'S
COMPLICATED IN SOME INSTANCES,
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE WERE
SEEING KIND OF THIS
PSYCHOLOGICAL ABUSE IS THAT
OFFICERS WILL TURN OTHER
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AGAINST
SOMEONE WHO IS A SURVIVOR. SO IF
THAT PERSON REPORTS, THE OFFICER
MIGHT PUT OUT A HIT ON THEM. SO
SOMETIMES WE SEE SURVIVORS WHO
ARE PLACED IN RESTRICTED HOUSING
BECAUSE REPORTS CAME ON IN ON
THEM AFTER THEY MADE THEIR
REPORT. SO, IT'S A LITTLE
COMPLICATED. AND THERE CAN BE
THINGS THAT ARE DISGUISED AS
STANDARD PRACTICE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY VEILED RETALIATION.
THANK YOU. WELL, I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU DO, AND MY
HOPE, OBVIOUSLY, IS THAT, YOUR
COURAGEOUS WORK TOGETHER WITH
CDCR, WE REALLY JUST PUT AN END.
I APPRECIATE ALSO ONE OF YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS BEING THAT FOR
THE SAFETY OF SURVIVORS THAT
RELEASE, SHOULD BE, SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION FOR ANY OF THE FOR
ANY OF THE VICTIMS, AND THEN IN
TERMS OF THE FUNDING, DO YOU
INTEND. I GUESS THIS IS FOR
CDCR. IS THE FUNDING ALLOCATED
FOR THE WORKING GROUP GOING TO
BE PART OF IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
$250,000? I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S
THE EXACT AMOUNT, BUT YEAH, I
THINK MY QUESTION MORE THAN
ANYTHING, IS FUNDING TO
IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT? WHAT
ANYTHING MORE THAT WE CAN DO TO
BE HELPFUL. RIGHT. WE I DO HAVE
BMB HERE AND I THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO COMMENT ON THAT. I WILL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU WITH
THAT RESPONSE. I DON'T HAVE THAT
AT THIS TIME, BUT WE. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. JUSTIN
EDELMAN, ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
BUDGET MANAGEMENT BRANCH. THE
ONE TIME FUNDING WAS ONE TIME
AGAIN FOR THE WORK GROUP. SO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ONGOING RESOURCES
DEDICATED TO KIND OF
IMPLEMENTING RECOMMENDATIONS AS.
HERE. THAT WOULD BE A GREAT
CONSIDERATION. YES. YOU AGAIN, I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT, AND I
SAID IT IN OUR LAST ITEM AND I
REALLY WANT TO STRESS THIS WITH
THE INMATES BEING LOCKED UP 24
HOURS A DAY. AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. I'M
TALKING ABOUT JUST THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE IN PRISON. AND WE CAN
CONSIDER, SEE AGAIN, AN INCREASE
IN THE BUDGET FOR CDCR ACROSS
THE BOARD WITH A DECREASE IN
POPULATION. RIGHT. REGARDLESS OF
PROP 47 OR NOT. WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING THIS TREND. WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT IN PREVIOUS, MEETINGS,
ENSURING THAT INMATES HAVE AN
ACTIVITY, ENSURING THAT WE ARE,
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, MAKING SURE
THAT THEY SPEND EIGHT HOURS A
DAY EITHER IN EDUCATION
PROGRAMS, POTENTIALLY GETTING A
GED, A DEGREE, SOMETHING,
VALUABLE WORK SKILL. AND I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT SEWING, WHICH IS
OFFERED IN SOME OF THE PRISONS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT REAL LIFE
SKILLS THAT ONCE THEY ARE
RELEASED, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REHABILITATE THÀNH, THAT
THEY HAVE SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN UTILIZE IN THE REST OF
SOCIETY. RIGHT, AND AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, EVEN IN THE LAST ITEM
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT, THE
REFORMS AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT ARE ON THE TABLE, THEY ARE
POSITIVE OF, THEY ARE TO IMPROVE
THE PROGRAM. AND I OFTEN FEEL,
WHETHER AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OR
THE STATE LEVEL, THAT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A PIECE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WHETHER IT IS OUR
PRISON SYSTEMS OR JAILS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND POLICE AS A
WHOLE, THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF PUSHBACK AND ALWAYS A
REQUEST FOR MORE FUNDS FOR TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGY AND SO FORTH, BUT
NOT NECESSARILY ON STRATEGY. AND
IT'S A LITTLE FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MODEL IN CALIFORNIA,
AND WE HAVE OTHER MODELS ACROSS
THE WORLD, WHETHER WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NORWAY OR ANYTHING ELSE,
THE REALITY IS THAT IF WE ARE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
ARE DOING SOMETHING PRODUCTIVE
AND WORKING ON THEMSELVES, IT
REDUCES A LOT OF RISK FOR
OFFICERS. IT ENSURES THAT THERE
IS A BETTER MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENT FOR THE INMATES, IT IS
SAFER. IT IS BETTER FOR ALL OF
SOCIETY. SO I REALLY WANT TO SAY
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
REFORMS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, AS WELL AS INVESTING
IN PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
INMATES AS A WHOLE. SO ONE TIME
FUNDS. GREAT. WE DO NEED LONG
TERM FUNDING, AND AS MUCH AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUDGET CUTS
THIS YEAR AND AGAIN, I'M GOING
TO HIGHLIGHT THIS THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS, RIGHT. THAT'S
THE HONEST OUTLOOK OF OUR
BUDGET, WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE PRIORITIZING STRATEGIC
IMPROVEMENTS EVEN WITH A
DOWNFALL. AND I DON'T SEE ENOUGH
OF THAT. AND IT IS BENEFICIAL
THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT, IS THAT WE ALSO
VERY MUCH FOCUS ON
REHABILITATION. A LOT OF THE
INMATES, THEY WERE NOT TALKING
ABOUT JUST THE SEXUAL ASSAULTS
THAT HAPPENED IN PRISONS. MANY
OF THEM ARE VICTIMS PRIOR TO
ENTERING THE SYSTEM, MEN AND
WOMEN. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
TRAUMA WITH THAT. THERE'S A LOT
OF AND WHEN YOU HAVE ENOUGH TIME
ON YOUR HANDS WHERE YOU'RE JUST
FOCUSING ON YOUR LIFE AND HOW
YOU GOT TO WHERE YOU'RE AT, IT
IS VERY TAXING. SO AS MUCH AS WE
CAN INVEST IN MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT AND THERAPY AND MUCH
MORE, AS WELL AS JUST COUNSELING
AND PROGRAMING AND MUCH MORE,
THAT IS WHERE OUR DOLLARS SHOULD
BE USED BECAUSE IT KEEPS IT
SAFER FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT, FOR
CDCR. AND IT DOES CHANGE AND
IMPROVE THE IMAGE AGAIN ACROSS
THE BOARD. CDCR HAS A
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN HERE. WE
HAVE, AND I'M TELLING YOU THIS,
AS CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY AS
WELL AS CHAIR OF BUDGET SUB
FIVE, I GET REPORTS REGULARLY
AND MAIL REGULARLY FROM INMATES
TALKING ABOUT THEIR THEIR
SITUATION. RIGHT. SO I DO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT I REALLY
DO THANK THE WORK THAT YOU GUYS
ARE ALL DOING. I APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION AND THE EFFORT IN
THIS SPACE. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE AVERAGE INDIVIDUAL
ALSO CARES ABOUT BECAUSE SEX,
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN OUR PRISONS
SHOULD NOT EXIST. INMATE VERSUS
INMATE OR, YOU KNOW, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENT VERSUS INMATE.
RIGHT SHOULD NOT EXIST. THIS
SHOULD BE THE SAFEST SPACE. AND
THE FACT THAT AND I'M GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS, THE REASON WHY
WE HAVE THE BODY CAMS IS BECAUSE
IN ONE OF THE STATE PRISONS LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS BASICALLY HAVING
A RING OF LIKE A GLADIATOR TYPE
OF EFFORT WHERE THEY WERE
PUTTING BETS ON WHICH INMATE CAN
BEAT UP WHICH INMATE. THAT IS
DISGUSTING. SO AGAIN, WE NEED TO
INCREASE THE STANDARD OF WHAT WE
CONSIDER IN REGARDS TO
APPROPRIATENESS AND DIGNITY
AMONGST OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT, BUT
ALSO THE DIGNITY OF THE INMATES.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS
. SO I REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
ISSUE AREA, AND LET'S TALK ABOUT
ISSUE ITEM NUMBER 33, SAN
QUENTIN REHABILITATION CENTER
UPDATE. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
DAVE LEWIS, DIRECTOR OF FACILITY
PLANNING, CONSTRUCTION AND
MANAGEMENT AT CDCR. HI THERE.
HELLO. GOOD MORNING, I'M DAVE
LEWIS. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT FOR CDCR, AND I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
AND PRESENT ON SAN QUENTIN, SAN
QUENTIN, WHEN I WAS APPOINTED TO
THIS POSITION IN FEBRUARY OF
LAST YEAR, I WAS TOLD THAT SAN
QUENTIN WAS PROBABLY GOING TO BE
A PRIORITY, AND SO WE STARTED
LOOKING AT WHAT PLANS MIGHT BE,
AND THE GOVERNOR SAT DOWN,
OBVIOUSLY, AND HE PRESENTED A
PLAN TO, TO CREATE AN EDUCATION
CENTER AT SAN QUENTIN BY
DECEMBER OF 2025. OUR PLANS AT
THAT POINT REPRESENT NOTED
SIMILAR, SCOPE, BUT THE TIME
FRAME WAS MORE LIKE DECEMBER OF
2029, AND SO WE AT THAT POINT
HAD APPROXIMATELY 33 MONTHS TO
COMPLETE THIS PROJECT. SO WE'VE
BEEN MOVING AT THE SPEED OF
LIGHT IN ORDER TO MEET THE
GOVERNOR'S MANDATE OF COMPLETING
A PROJECT BY DECEMBER OF 2025,
AT THIS POINT, WE'RE,
APPROXIMATELY A MONTH BEHIND
SCHEDULE, JUST DUE TO CHANGES
THAT WERE NECESSARY, RELATED TO
THE ADVISORY COUNCIL
RECOMMENDATIONS TO REDUCE THE
COST OF THE PROJECT TO, BY
APPROXIMATELY A THIRD TO ABOUT
$240 MILLION, AND SO WE'RE NOW
LOOKING AT COMPLETION IN JANUARY
OF 2026, AS PART OF THIS PROCESS
, WE CONTRACTED WITH MCCARTHY
AND BUILDING COMPANY AND DLR
GROUP AND SCHMIDT HAMMER LASSEN,
TO DO THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF THE FACILITY.
AND THAT CONTRACT WAS LET IN
SEPTEMBER. AT THIS POINT, AND I
PROVIDED A HANDOUT OF SOME
RENDERINGS OF THE PROJECT, AND
WE'RE ABOUT DONE WITH DESIGN
DRAWINGS AND ABOUT TO BEGIN THE
CONSTRUCTION DRAWING PHASE, OF
THE DESIGN PROCESS, AS FAR AS
THE CONSTRUCTION ITSELF, THE
DEMOLITION PHASE HAS BEGUN, AND
THIS WEEK WE'VE ACTUALLY TORE
OUT PART OF THE NORTH WALL,
WHICH WILL BE THE ACCESS TO THE
CONSTRUCTION SITE TO ALLOW US TO
EXPEDITE AND NOT HAVE TO ACCESS
THE SITE THROUGH THE INSTITUTION
. THÀNH WILL BE ACCESSING
THROUGH THE EXTERIOR WALL
INSTEAD, AND THIS WILL ALLOW US
TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS OF
CONSTRUCTION, THROUGHOUT. SO
WE'VE BEGUN THE DEMOLITION. WE
ANTICIPATE BEGINNING THE
DEMOLITION OF BUILDING 38
ITSELF, SOMETIME AT THE END OF
THIS MONTH OR BEGINNING OF NEXT
MONTH AND BEGINNING CONSTRUCTION
SITE WORK OVER THE SUMMER AND
BEGINNING CONSTRUCTION OF THE
ACTUAL BUILDINGS IN LATE SUMMER,
EARLY FALL OF THIS YEAR, LIKE I
SAID, WE PROVIDED A HANDOUT THAT
HAS SOME, SOME DESIGN, DRAWINGS
IN THEM. AND THESE ARE
CONCEPTUAL DESIGN. I DO HAVE TO
TELL YOU, THEY REFLECT, THE
SCHEMATIC PHASE OF DESIGN, AND
THERE WILL BE CHANGES AS WE GO
ALONG TO REFLECT, WORKING WITH
THE FIRE MARSHAL, WORKING WITH
CONTINUED WORKING WITH USER
GROUPS TO GATHER INPUT, FOR
EXAMPLE, THEY WON'T BE WHITE
BUILDINGS, THEY WILL BE SOME
OTHER COLOR. AND WE'RE WORKING
ON THAT RIGHT NOW. THE, THE
PALETTE OF, THAT WE WILL USE, WE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL DURING THEIR
DELIBERATIONS. AND SO WE WERE
WELL AWARE OF WHAT THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL'S RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD
BE, THE THIRD CUT IN THE BUDGET
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE HAD TO
MAKE A PAUSE AND SO WE COULD
MEET THOSE EXPECTATIONS. DOES
DRIVING DESIGN PHILOSOPHIES HERE
ARE REALLY ABOUT CREATING A
TRANSFORMATIVE ENVIRONMENT THAT
DOESN'T REFLECT CURRENT
EDUCATIONAL SETTINGS IN A
CORRECTIONAL ENVIRONMENT? AND
YOU CAN SEE THAT IN THOSE
PICTURES. THIS WE WERE GOING FOR
A CAMPUS APPROACH THAT CREATED A
MORE NORMAL, ENVIRONMENT THAT
YOU WOULD SEE IN ANY COLLEGE
CAMPUS OR ANYWHERE ELSE. AND WE
CONTINUE TO MEET OUR, OUR,
CONDITIONS OF SATISFACTION AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROJECT,
WHICH WERE REALLY FOCUSED ON
CREATING SOMETHING THAT DIDN'T
REFLECT OUR CURRENT, OUR CURRENT
STANDARDS, OUR CURRENT BUILDINGS
, AND FINDING DIFFERENT WAYS AND
INNOVATIVE WAYS OF DOING BOTH
CONSTRUCTION AND ALSO PROVIDING
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE EXPECT TO
BE SERVED HERE, THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS, WE'VE MET WITH WITH
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE, BOTH AT SAN
QUENTIN, COMMUNITY ADVOCATES,
THE ARCHITECTS ON THIS PROJECT
ARE PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
EDUCATIONAL PROJECTS AND LIBRARY
PROJECTS, NOT CORRECTIONAL
PROJECTS, THOUGH OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO KEEP THOSE THINGS IN
MIND AS WELL. SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID, I'M OPEN TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU, DO WE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES? SENATOR SATO? SO WE
HAVE WE HAVE, SOME OF OUR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS BEING
TRANSFERRED AROUND TO DO JOBS SO
THAT THEY CAN WORK OFF THEIR
RESTITUTION. THÀNH ARE THEY
USING ANY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO BE PART OF THE
LABOR FORCE TO BUILD THIS, WE
ARE EXAMINING A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT IN THE
FUTURE. AND WITH THE SPEED OF
THIS PROJECT, IT REALLY WASN'T
SOMETHING WE HAD THE TIME TO
LOOK AT. ONE THING, THOUGH, THAT
WE ARE DOING IS TRYING TO, IN A
NORMAL SITUATION IN CONSTRUCTION
AND CDCR, IF YOU HAVE, FOR
EXAMPLE, A PRIOR FELONY, THEN
YOU'RE EXCLUDED. ACCESS TO CCR
INSTITUTIONS. SO THAT GENERALLY
LIMITS THE PEOPLE THAT CAN CAN
PARTICIPATE. AND WE'RE TRYING
VERY HARD TO LIMIT ANY
EXCLUSIONS FROM THE WORKFORCE
THAT HAVE THOSE KINDS OF
EXCLUSIONS. BUT AT THIS POINT,
WE DON'T WE HAVE NOT, INCLUDED
THE INCARCERATED, CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN THE WORKFORCE,
JUST LARGELY DUE TO THE TIME.
AND WE DID HAVE SOME DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT IT. BUT, THE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND WORKING WITH THE, THE
LOCAL LOCAL LABOR UNIONS THAT
PROVIDE STAFF AND THERE JUST
WASN'T THE TIME THAT WE NEEDED
TO COMPLETE THAT REVIEW. IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT WHAT AN IDEAL
PROJECT TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO WERE
TRYING TO KEEP BUSY AND GIVE
RESTITUTION, TO THEIR, THEIR,
THEIR VICTIMS TO BE ACTUALLY
WORKING ON SOMETHING THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN TAKE
INTO THE REAL WORLD WHEN THEY'RE
WHEN THEY'RE DONE. AND I'M
REALLY PERPLEXED THAT THEY WOULD
SEND PEOPLE FROM A INSTITUTION
THAT IS, A HIGHER SECURITY TO AN
INSTITUTION THAT HAS MUCH LOWER
SECURITY TO DO A JOB THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO GET PAID FOR
WHEN WE HAVE THIS KIND OF
PROJECT IN THEIR BACK YARD. SO
ANYWAY, THAT'S NOT YOUR AREA,
BUT I JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHO
WERE WHO WERE USING, TO HELP
BUILD AND WHY WE'RE NOT USING
MORE PRISONERS. SENATOR NEWMAN.
VERY BRIEFLY, MR. LEWIS, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY.
AND THIS IS ENCOURAGING, MY
CONCERN IS MORE GENERALLY, I
THINK IT'S WONDERFUL WHAT WE'RE
DOING AT SAN QUENTIN, AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK, BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE BUDGET
CONSTRAINTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ELIMINATED TODAY, THAT WE MAKE A
DELIBERATE EFFORT TO EXTEND
THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS INTO
OTHER FACILITIES. I KNOW THAT'S
NOT YOUR JURISDICTION, BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO PUT THAT
ON THE RECORD HERE TODAY. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DURAZZO. THANK YOU, AS I
UNDERSTAND, YOU HAVE THE WORKING
GROUP, THE RECOMMENDATIONS,
RIGHT? LIKE 150 RECOMMENDATIONS.
YES THERE'S 150 PAGES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS. A LOT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL. YES BUT IT IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE ONLY
RECOMMENDATION YOU'RE
IMPLEMENTING IS TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WHAT HAPPENS
TO ALL OF THE WORK OF THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL OR GROUP? AND
150 PAGES OF RECOMMENDATIONS? SO
MOST OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THE ADVISORY COUNCIL ARE REALLY
OPERATIONAL OR PROGRAM RELATED
RECOMMENDATIONS. THERE'S
RELATIVELY FEW FACILITY RELATED
QUESTIONS, RECOMMENDATIONS
OUTSIDE OF SOME DISCUSSION OF
THE FUTURE OF EAST BLOCK AND THE
HOUSING, FOR EXAMPLE, ALL,
REALLY THE ONLY RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO THIS CAMPUS WERE,
WERE THINGS RELATED TO CREATING
AN OPEN ENVIRONMENT AND CREATING
A WHAT WE ARE DOING. AND SO
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS, WE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL, THE REMAINDER OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS CREATED VARIOUS TRACKING AND
ARE LOOKING AT EACH ONE OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE THEY
REALLY ARE OPERATIONAL AND
THEY'RE NOT WITHIN MY PURVIEW,
BUT THE DEPARTMENT IS EXAMINING
ALL OF THOSE AND HOW THOSE CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED, IF APPROPRIATE,
OR HOW, SOME THING SIMILAR CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED IF IT DOESN'T
REALLY MATCH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS, AND I
THINK A LOT OF THOSE EXTEND
BEYOND SAN QUENTIN, FOR EXAMPLE,
AND REALLY ARE IMPORTANT BEYOND
SAN QUENTIN ITSELF. BUT THE
DEPARTMENT IS EXAMINING ALL OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS AND SEEING
HOW THEY CAN BE IMPLEMENTED AT
THIS TIME, THE REASON I ASK IS
BECAUSE THE INDIVIDUALS ON THAT
COUNCIL WHO CAME TO VISIT MANY
OF US, REALLY THEIR EMPHASIS WAS
ON THE PROGRAMMATIC AND THE
QUESTIONS WE RAISED WERE ABOUT
THE PROGRAMS BECAUSE HAVING A
NEW BUILDING, WELL, IT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE. AND IT'S AND IT'S
VERY POSITIVE. THE REAL ISSUES
ARE PROGRAMS. THE REAL ISSUES
ARE TRAINING OF STAFF. THE REAL
ISSUES ARE HOW DO YOU CHANGE THE
CULTURE. AND SO MY CONCERN IS
WE'RE DOING REALLY GREAT ON THE
CONSTRUCTION SIDE OF IT. RIGHT
BY JANUARY OF 2026, BUT I DON'T
HEAR ANYTHING BACK ABOUT THE
PROGRAM. AND, AND I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU'RE IN CHARGE OF, BUT
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO BE IN CHARGE
OF IT. AND WE'VE GOT TO HEAR
WHAT IS GOING ON TO PREPARE FOR
THAT. IT'S NOT LIKE YOU OPEN
YOUR DOORS AND THEN THE PROGRAM
IS DONE AND SET THERE. PROGRAM
ALSO TAKES A LOT OF TIME. SO HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THOUGH 95%
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE DULY
IMPLEMENTED, UNDERSTOOD. AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS?
AND CAN YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA OF
WHAT WE CAN? CAN YOU GIVE ME AN
IDEA OF WHEN WE CAN EXPECT
RESULTS ON ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS, AS AGAIN, MY
PIECE IS A LITTLE PIECE OF THE
OVERALL REPORT AND I HAVEN'T
BEEN FULLY INVOLVED IN ALL OF
THOSE EFFORTS, BUT I CERTAINLY
THINK YOU WILL START TO SEE SOME
OF THOSE, AS WE BEGIN TO RIGHT
NOW, WE'RE TRANSFERRING OUT THE
CONDEMNED INMATE POPULATION
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, THAT
CREATES OPPORTUNITIES AROUND
HOUSING AND SOME OTHER THINGS.
AND CERTAINLY DRP, THE DIVISION
OF REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS, IS
IN A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE FUTURE PROGRAMS THAT WILL BE
HOUSED AT SAN QUENTIN. AND WE'VE
MET WITH MANY, MANY
STAKEHOLDERS, INCLUDING THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE IMPACTED
BY THIS CONSTRUCTION ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS RELATED TO
THAT, IN ADDITION, THE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
THAT IMPACT ALL AREAS OF SAN
QUENTIN AND OTHER INSTITUTIONS
ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THE INTENTION OF THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL REPORT. AND I
THINK YOU WILL START TO SEE SOME
OF THOSE IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE. AND COULD I GET A,
CORRECT THAT THE $20 MILLION WAS
IS UNUSED, AT THIS POINT, YES,
WE HAVEN'T DEVELOPED A COMPLETE
PLAN FOR THE $20 MILLION.
OUTSIDE OF THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THIS FACILITY. AND WE WERE
REALLY WAITING FOR THE ADVISORY
COUNCIL REPORT TO BE RELEASED
BEFORE WE DEVELOPED PLANS,
RELATED TO THE $20 MILLION, AND
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S ALSO KIND OF
TIED UP IN SOME BUDGET ISSUES
RELATED TO THE COST, I'D LIKE TO
SUGGEST I HAVE A REALLY GOOD
IDEA FOR THE $20 MILLION, THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH THE KIND OF
PROGRAM INSIDE THE REST OF THE,
INSTITUTIONS FOR WHAT WE WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT, THAT BADLY
NEEDS IT. SO THOSE KIND OF
REENTRY TRAINING PROGRAMS IS A
GREAT PLACE. SO I WOULD HIGHLY
SUGGEST THAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON, THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM, SO NO
ACTION IS NEEDED. WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER 34. FREE VOICE
CALLING SB 1008. WE'RE GOING TO
FIRST HEAR FROM CDCR.
IS THIS GOOD? GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR, MY NAME IS EDMUND
BLAGDEN. I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ENTERPRISE INFORMATION
SERVICES WITH CDCR. I'M HERE TO
DISCUSS SB 1008, WHICH PROVIDES
FREE CALLING TO THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION AND THEIR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. HISTORY. IN RESPONSE TO
CHAPTER 827 STATUTES OF 2022, SB
1008, WHICH GUARANTEED WHICH
GUARANTEED FREE VOICE CALLING
FOR THE INCARCERATED POPULATION
AND THEIR FAMILY AND FRIENDS,
THE BUDGET OF 2023 ACT PROVIDED
28.5 MILLION IN 23, 24 AND
ONGOING TO PROVIDE FREE VOICE
CALLING AT THE TIME, CALLING
STRUCTURE UTILIZED TIERED
CALLING PLAN, DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL CALLS BEING THE
SAME PRICE PER MINUTE. MONTHLY
CALL VOLUMES ARE CHARGED AT THE
FOLLOWING TIER ONE 0 TO 45
MILLION CALLS PER MONTH AT 2922
POINT $0.09 PER MINUTE. TIER TWO
IS 45 MILLION TO 75 MILLION
CALLS AT 2.5 CENTS PER MINUTE,
AND TIER THREE OVER 75 MILLION
CALLS PER MONTH. AT 22.2 CENTS
PER MINUTE. THE ESTIMATE WAS
BASED OFF OF JANUARY, FEBRUARY
AND MARCH 2023 CALL VOLUMES AND
TRENDS, WHICH WERE ABOUT
93,000,000 MINUTES PER MONTH OR
1.1 BILLION ANNUAL MINUTES.
CURRENTLY VÆ. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDED A CURRENT YEAR
REQUEST FOR 7.4 MILLION AND AN
AND A 8.2 MILLION REQUEST IN
2024, 25 AND ONGOING TO REFLECT
AN INCREASE IN CALL VOLUME,
PROJECTING ABOUT 1.5 BILLION
ANNUAL MINUTES IN FISCAL YEARS
23, 24 AND 2425. ONE REASON FOR
THIS INCREASE IS THE COMPLETION
OF THE TABLET ROLLOUTS
THROUGHOUT THE INSTITUTIONS,
WHICH BEGAN WITH VALLEY STATE
PRISON IN AUGUST OF 21 AND WAS
COMPLETED IN SEPTEMBER OF 23 AT
CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY. WE WILL
REFINE THESE ESTIMATES AS PART
OF THE MAY REVISION, AS WE
INCORPORATE ADDITIONAL MONTHS OF
ACTUAL CALL VOLUME DATA. THESE
CONTRACTED SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
BY VIAPATH TECHNOLOGIES. IN JUNE
23RD, WE VACATED THE CONTRACT
WITH VIAPATH TECHNOLOGIES AS A
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
ORDERED REQUIRING IT BE SET
ASIDE TOOK EFFECT AS ALSO
PERMITTED BY THE COURT'S ORDER,
CDCR HAS ENTERED INTO EMERGENCY
INTERIM CONTRACT WITH VIAPATH TO
KEEP ALL EXISTING COMMUNICATION
SERVICES FULLY OPERATIONAL UNTIL
WE'RE ABLE TO COMPLETE THE BID
PROCESS FOR A PERMANENT CONTRACT
FOR THESE SERVICES, EXISTING
TABLET AND PHONE SERVICES WILL
BE MAINTAINED DURING THIS
INTERIM PERIOD, BUT NO
ADDITIONAL SERVICES WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL THE PERMANENT
CONTRACT IS IN PLACE. THERE WILL
BE NO GAP IN SERVICE DURING THIS
TRANSITION, AS WE ENTER INTO A
ONE YEAR CONTRACT WITH THREE
OPTIONAL SIX MONTH EXTENSIONS TO
CONTINUE EXISTING SERVICES UNTIL
WE TRANSITION TO THIS NEW
CONTRACT. WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY ON THE
NEW SOLICITATION. WE HAVE
CONDUCTED OUTREACH AND RECEIVED
FEEDBACK FROM MANY STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING THE POPULATION, FAMILY
AND FRIENDS, TO ENSURE WE ARE
ABLE TO MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS IN
THE FUTURE CONTRACT. BECAUSE ITS
ACTIVE SOLUTION, WE CANNOT
PROVIDE MANY DETAILS TODAY.
HOWEVER, THE CURRENT ROLLOUT,
THE CURRENT ROUTING OF THE
SOLICITATION SCHEDULE FOR
APPROVAL AND WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT ONCE IT IS
FINALIZED AND APPROVED. I'M
HAPPY TO FIELD ANY QUESTIONS AND
HAVE MY, SYLVIA DUMALAG AND
TRISTAN LEMMON WITH ME TO FIELD
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LEO. CAITLYN O'NEILL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. MY
OUR RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ITEM
IS REALLY JUST RELATED TO A
TECHNICAL BUDGETING ISSUE, WHICH
IS THAT THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
ASSUMES OR IS BASED ON ACTUAL
CALLING USAGE AND COSTS FROM
AUGUST OF 2023, AND ASSUMES THAT
THAT LEVEL WILL REMAIN FLAT
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET YEAR. SO
THROUGH JUNE 2025, AND HOWEVER,
THE POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO
DECLINE OVER THAT PERIOD. SO
ASSUMING THAT EACH PERSON, USES
ROUGHLY THE SAME AMOUNT OF
MINUTES PER MONTH, WE WOULD
EXPECT THE TOTAL COST TO GO DOWN
AS WELL. SO WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION ON
THIS, THE PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME
AND DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
SUBMIT A REVISED METHODOLOGY AT
THE MAY REVISION THAT REFLECTS
NOT ONLY REVISED ADDITIONAL
MONTHS OF ACTUAL CALLING COST
DATA, WHICH THEY ALREADY INTEND
TO DO, BUT ALSO ADJUSTS THE
PROJECTION GOING FORWARD FOR
CHANGES IN THE POPULATION, AND
THIS, WE THINK, WOULD PROMOTE
MORE ACCURATE BUDGETING IN
GENERAL, BUT ALSO COULD FREE UP
SOME MONEY IN THE BUDGET YEAR TO
HELP WITH THE FISCAL CONDITION.
THANK YOU, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
. JOSHUA WITTMERSHAUS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
NOTE THAT SB 1008 WAS ONLY
RECENTLY ENACTED, AND WE'RE
WORKING WITHIN A RELATIVELY
LIMITED DATA SET TO PROJECT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH FREE
CALLING. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITY IS TO MAKE SURE THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF RESOURCES
IS AVAILABLE TO FUND FREE VOICE
CALLING, AS REQUIRED BY THE
LEGISLATION. THE ADMINISTRATION
LOOKS FORWARD TO PROVIDING
UPDATES AT MÀ. REVISION THANK
YOU. ANY COLLEAGUES? YES.
SENATOR RUSSELL? YES, I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE CONTRACT WITH
VÌ VIAPATH. I KNOW THAT THERE
HAD BEEN MANY PROBLEMS RIGHT?
CALLS GETTING DISCONNECTED,
CROSSTALK, SERVICE GOING DOWN
OVER A MAJOR HOLIDAYS, THEY RUN
THE VISITATION AND THE BOOKING
SOFTWARE FOR WOULD GET
OVERWHELMED, BY VOLUME. SO WHAT
ARE YOU DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN? AND
ANOTHER CONTRACT WOULD BUY A
PATH. SO WE ACTIVELY WORK WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND WITH THE
CONTRACT PROVIDERS. SO ANY OF
THESE ISSUES THAT DO ARISE, WE
JUMP ON THEM AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. WE HAVE A DEDICATED
TEAM WORKING WITH VIAPATH ON A
REGULAR BASIS. WE WOULD CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH EITHER VIAPATH OR
WHOEVER WINS THE NEW CONTRACT TO
MAKE SURE THOSE ARE RESOLVED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. YEAH, YOU
KNOW, THIS ISN'T YOU AND ME AND
OUR CONNECTION GETS LOST. THIS
IS LIKE A FAMILY TRAVELING TO
VISIT A LOVED ONE. AND, YOU
KNOW, THEIR RESERVATION OR THEIR
APPOINTMENT GETS SCREWED UP OR
CANCELED, OR THEY DIDN'T KNOW
THAT. SO THERE'S A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE, VERY IMPACTFUL
RESULTS AND OUTCOMES FROM THIS
NOT WORKING RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANKS, SO, YOU KNOW, JUST
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH SENATOR
ROUSE'S COUNSEL. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADDITIONAL SERVICES, THE PREMIUM
SERVICES OFFERED BY VIAPATH ON
TOP OF FREE CALLING, ARE THERE
OTHER VENDOR OPTIONS OR ARE THEY
THE SOLE PROVIDER OF THESE
PREMIUM SERVICES? THIS IS SYLVIA
Dð MOORLACH, THE WAY THAT THE
SOLICITATION WAS, WENT OUT, IT
WAS AN ALL INCLUSIVE CONTRACT SO
THAT ALL THOSE SERVICES ARE
BUNDLED TOGETHER CURRENTLY. AND,
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHY THEY
PROVIDE ALL OF THOSE SERVICES
TOGETHER. SO LIKE EDWIN SAID,
WE'RE WORKING ON A NEW
SOLICITATION THÀNH, AND SO WE
CAN'T GO INTO THE DETAILS OF
EVERYTHING THAT WILL BE INCLUDED
IN THE NEW SOLICITATION. BUT,
THAT'S THAT'S THE REASON WHY IT
IS THAT WAY TODAY. IS THERE ANY
REASON WHY THAT THAT A NEW
SOLICITATION WOULDN'T INCLUDE AN
OPTION FOR SECOND OR THIRD
VENDORS TO PROVIDE SOME
COMPETITION FOR THESE PREMIUM
SERVICES? LIKE I SAID, THERE
IT'LL BE IT'LL BE UP TO THE
BIDDERS ON HOW THEY WANT TO
PROVIDE WHATEVER REQUIREMENTS
ARE WITHIN THAT. THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE NEW
CONTRACT. OKAY. LET ME ASK YOU.
I MEAN, WE'VE BEEN GIVEN A TABLE
HERE. THERE'S A REFERENCE TO
IMESSAGES, WHICH I ASSUME ARE
TEXT MESSAGES. IS THAT IT? IT'S
ELECTRONIC MESSAGING. SO, IT CAN
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT EMAIL, SOME
PEOPLE CALL IT MESSAGING. BUT
YEAH, $0.05 A MESSAGE. CORRECT.
THAT'S WAY MORE THAN WE PAY.
RIGHT? SO I YOU KNOW, I'D URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER HOW TO CONSTRUCT
THAT SOLICITATION SO THAT THE
PREMIUM TIER DOESN'T WIND UP
BEING EXTREMELY ONEROUS FOR
INMATES. RIGHT. AND WE HOPE,
AGAIN, WITH THE COMPETITIVE
SOLICITATION WITH MULTIPLE
BIDDERS COMING TO THE TABLE,
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE POINTS
THAT WILL, YOU KNOW, ENABLE
COMPETITION. AND WILL WE HEAR
ABOUT THIS AS IT'S ONGOING OR.
OKAY. THANK YOU. SO I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS. AND DO YOU
GUYS TIME THE INMATES AND HOW
MUCH USAGE THEY HAVE. AND DO YOU
WANT TO ANSWER. NO RIGHT NOW
UNLIMITED CALLING. SO IF THEY'RE
TRISTAN LEMMON ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR FOR, GPM MISSION WITH
THE I, IT'S ABOUT HOURS OF
OPERATION WHEN THEY HAVE ACCESS
TO THE TABLETS AND SO THOSE
PHONE CALLS WOULD JUST BE THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS OPENLY DURING,
MAYBE DAY ROOM HOURS OR WHATEVER
THE LOCAL SCHEDULE IS AT THE
INSTITUTION, THE ONLY PHONES
THAT DO HAVE A GENERAL 15 MINUTE
TIME LIMIT ARE, ARE THE ACTUAL
PHONES THAT ARE IN A HOUSING
UNIT THAT ARE NOT A PART OF THE
TABLET, OR MAYBE ON A YARD. ALL
RIGHT. SO WHY ARE THE POLICIES
DIFFERENT, BECAUSE THE TABLET
ACCESS IS OVER, OVER THAT
NETWORK. AND THEN THE PHONES ON
THE WALLS ARE JUST, THAT'S JUST
BEEN THE PRACTICE WITH THOSE. SO
THEY WEREN'T THEY WEREN'T LOOKED
AT AS THE SAME THE SAME PROCESS
BECAUSE THE TABLET IS JUST
ACCESS TO THEIR OWN PERSONAL
DEVICE AND THE PHONES THAT ARE
OPEN TO THE REST OF THE
POPULATION AREN'T THEIRS
PERSONALLY. SO THEY'RE SHARED
AMONGST THE POPULATION. OKAY. SO
EVERY SINGLE INMATE HAS ACCESS
TO A TABLET. OKAY. AND
CONSIDERING THAT, YOU KNOW, I
THINK MANY OF US AS SENATOR
NEWMAN STATED, WE COULD HAVE A
SUBSCRIPTION PLAN THAT'S $25 A
MONTH, UNLIMITED EVERYTHING. SO
WHY ARE WE PAYING $0.05 HERE?
$0.20 PER MINUTE? THERE $5, $6
SOMEWHERE ELSE, $2 A MONTH. WHY
I BELIEVE THAT'S SOMETHING WE
COULD RESOLVE WITH A NEW
CONTRACT. SO IT'S THE RATE
STRUCTURE IN WHICH THAT
SOLICITATION WENT OUT. RIGHT. SO
YOU PUT TOGETHER, CAN THAT BE
CHANGED? IT COULD BE CHANGED. SO
IT SHOULD BE CHANGED, NUMBER
ONE. AND NUMBER TWO IS THE FACT
THAT IS THERE ANY REASON WHY WE
ARE PAYING THIS PREMIUM? IS IT A
SECURITY FEATURE? IS IT EXTRA
ANYTHING? THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TECHNOLOGY ON THE ON
THE BACKSIDE SIDE, THERE IS SOME
SECURITY THAT GOES INTO IT. IT
IS A BIT DIFFERENT THAN, THAN
THE WAY THAT WE UTILIZE OUR
TELEPHONES. THERE ARE, YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING IS SCREENED,
EVERYTHING IS RECORDED. THEY
PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE, FOR
THESE DEVICES TO WORK,
THROUGHOUT OUR INSTITUTIONS, OF
WHICH WE KNOW IS NOT EASY NOR
INEXPENSIVE. SO ALL OF THAT IS
KIND OF BUNDLED TOGETHER IN THE
SERVICE, PROVIDING THAT THEY
PROVIDE SO AN INDIVIDUAL CAN
SPEND EIGHT HOURS ON THIS
POTENTIALLY, IF THEY KEEP IT
CHARGED AND THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
PERMISSIONS. IT'S BASED OFF A
PRIVILEGED GROUP, AS FAR AS WHAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO. BUT, IF
THEY HAVE IT CHARGED, YEAH,
THERE'S OTHER ITEMS THAT ARE
ALSO WITHIN IT FOR FREE. SO
THERE'S, YOU KNOW, THERE'S BOOKS
ON THERE, THERE'S, WE PUT SOME
RESOURCES ON THERE LIKE TITLE 15
AND, PAROLE HANDBOOKS AND YOU
GUYS RECORD THE, THE PAYPHONE
VERSIONS, THE OLD 15 MINUTE
VERSIONS. CORRECT. DO YOU GUYS
RECORD COMMUNICATION HERE? YES.
OKAY. AND HOW OFTEN DO YOU GUYS
REVIEW, THAT'S SO, THAT'S
PERIODICALLY REVIEWED BY OUR
INVESTIGATOR, OUR INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES UNIT. ALSO SAME WITH
MESSAGES AND BUT THERE ISN'T A
CONSTANT LISTENING IN FEATURE.
IT'S POSSIBLE, BUT IT ISN'T. IT
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT WE DO. HOW
DO YOU ENSURE THIS? YOU KNOW,
THE MESSAGING, THE VIDEOS, THE
YOU KNOW, ALL OF THE THINGS THE
TELEPHONE CALLS, AND, AND SO
FORTH IS NOT USED FOR HARASSMENT
OF, POTENTIAL VICTIMS OR THINGS
LIKE THAT. AND SO OUR MESSAGES
ARE MONITORED, A LOT MORE, I
WOULD SAY, THAN THE, THAN THE
AUDIO CALLS. BUT WE ALSO HAVE
THE ABILITY AND USE THAT AS AN
INVESTIGATIVE TOOL. OR IF THERE
IS A COMPLAINT OR WHICH WE HAVE
RECEIVED AND WE TAKE ACTION AND
WE'RE ABLE TO ACTUALLY LISTEN TO
THE CONVERSATIONS OR SEE THE
MESSAGES ALSO ON, ON THE ON THE
PUBLIC SIDE, WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BLOCK ANY COMMUNICATION. SO I
WAS GETTING A PHONE CALL AND I
THAT I DIDN'T WANT TO, I WOULD
DECLINE IT. AND I HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BLOCK THE ABILITY FOR
THEM TO CALL ME. AND WHAT ABOUT
VIDEO CALLS? WHAT'S THAT? VIDEO
CALLS IS WHAT SENATOR NEWMAN IS
ASKING. DO YOU MONITOR AND
SCREEN AND RECORD VIDEO CALLS?
THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY. AND WHAT
IS THE COST ASSOCIATED TO THAT?
BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
STORED IN A SERVER SOMEWHERE,
RIGHT? SO AGAIN, THAT'S ALL
BUNDLED TOGETHER IN THE IN THE
RATES THAT, THAT THEY PROVIDE.
SO THAT'S PART OF THAT WHOLE
INCLUSIVE PACKAGE. OKAY. SO AS
AS MUCH AS I WANT TO PROVIDE A
LOT OF SERVICES AND SO FORTH,
HAVING AN UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF
ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES WITH
ADDITIONAL COST TO RECORDING AND
STORAGE AND, YOU KNOW, ENSURING
DATA IS NOT COMPROMISED AND MUCH
MORE. WHY ARE THERE NOT ANY
POLICIES AROUND THIS TO CONTROL
THIS AND CURB THIS? THE COST
WOULD BE EXPONENTIAL.
POTENTIALLY YOU MEAN POLICIES AS
FAR AS LIMITATIONS ON THAT?
POTENTIALLY, YES. BECAUSE IF
IT'S $0.20 PER MINUTE, WITH HOW
MANY INMATES FOR HOW MANY HOURS
PER HOW MANY DAYS? SO FOR EACH
SPECIFIC SITE, EACH FACILITY,
THEY WILL HAVE A, A LOCAL
PROCEDURE ON WHEN THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE TABLETS. SO IT
ISN'T NOT ALWAYS AROUND THE
CLOCK, THERE WILL BE TIMES WHEN
MAYBE THERE'S RECREATION TIME.
THAT WOULD BE THE TIME THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO. OKAY. SO
THE REASON OPERATIONAL SCHEDULE.
BUT IT'S DIFFERENT AT EACH
INSTITUTION. SO I ASKED EARLIER
IF THEY COULD POTENTIALLY BE ON
IT FOR EIGHT HOURS. AND YOU SAID
POTENTIALLY YES. RIGHT NOW MY
CONCERN IS THAT IF WE'RE
ALLOWING THIS WITH NO,
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE AND IF WE'RE
ALLOWING THIS COST TO BE SO
EXTRA, IF YOU WILL, YOU KNOW, I
DON'T WANT THIS PROGRAM AND THIS
EFFORT TO BE A FAILED PROGRAM TO
SAY, LOOK HOW MUCH IT COSTS. IT
COSTS SO MUCH MONEY. THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF THE
SAFEGUARDS, ANY SAFEGUARDS IN
REGARDS TO LIMITATIONS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IS CONCERNING
FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT. CAN I
ADD TO THAT? IS IT PREPAID?
COULD COULD AN INMATE GET INTO
DEBT IF THEY, YOU KNOW, RAN UP A
REALLY BIG BILL FOR AT $0.20 A
MINUTE FOR A VIDEO CALL IS THERE
IS THERE ANY LIMITATION ON THEIR
CREDIT AS PART OF THIS. SO THE,
THE VIDEO CALLS, I WANT TO
SEPARATE THE VIDEO CALLS A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE IT IS
DIFFERENT. SO THEY ARE THEY DO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
TELEPHONE CALLS VIA THE TABLET
FROM WHEREVER THEY HAVE
CONNECTIVITY VIDEO CALLS. THERE
ARE SPECIFIC LOCATIONS IN THE
OPEN AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE A
MOUNTING BRACKET, WHERE THEY CAN
PUT THE TABLET ON THERE TO USE
IT, OR THERE'S KIOSKS. SO I
THINK OPERATIONALLY THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS AROUND THAT AS FAR AS
TIMING ON WHEN THEY CAN ACCESS
THAT, AND THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. WHAT ABOUT THEIR
FINANCES THOUGH. RIGHT. FINANCES
IF THEY HAVE AN HOUR AND THEY
SPEAK FOR AN HOUR AND THAT'S
$0.20 TIMES 60 MINUTES, SO THEY
THE ALL CHARGES ARE, ARE EITHER
PAID FOR FROM THEIR TRUST
ACCOUNT OF WHICH THEY TRANSFER
MONEY ESSENTIALLY INTO THIS
MEDIA ACCOUNT, OR IF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE PAYING FOR IT, THEN
THE FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE THOSE
FUNDS WITHIN THEIR MEDIA ACCOUNT
. SO IT'S LIKE SO THIS IS
ACCOUNT PROBLEMATIC, IN THE
SENSE THAT FINANCIAL LITERACY IS
NOT WIDELY TAUGHT, MANY
INDIVIDUALS, YOU KNOW, I'M
DEPENDING ON HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
DO, LIKE THEY'RE SET UP FOR
FAILURE IF THERE'S NO
SAFEGUARDS. I DON'T KNOW HOW
THESE INMATES ARE BEING TRAINED
AND EDUCATED ON LIKE THESE ARE
THE COSTS. THIS IS HOW IT
HAPPENS, WHETHER THEY CARE OR
NOT ABOUT THE COST. IF YOU GUYS
HAVE LIMITATIONS OF LIKE IF YOU
HIT THIS NUMBER AND YOU DIDN'T
PAY, DO THEY PAY MONTHLY? DO
THEY PAY, YOU KNOW, YEARLY, THE
CHARGES, IF IT'S RELIANT ON THE
FAMILY, THAT'S NOT FAIR TO THE
FAMILY MEMBER EITHER. THE FACT
THAT THERE'S NO SAFEGUARDS TO
THIS PROGRAM IS PROBLEMATIC. YES
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY KIND OF
THE THRUST OF YOUR QUESTIONING.
SO I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT SB
1008, WHICH IS THE ENACTED
LEGISLATION, THAT THERE'S A
BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU ON,
REQUIRES CDCR TO PROVIDE FREE
VOICE CALLING, THERE ARE NO
LIMITATIONS INCLUDED IN THE
LEGISLATION. SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS SEEKING FOR CDCR
TO CHANGE ITS POLICIES, I THINK
THEY WOULD HAVE TO AMEND THE
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
REQUIRED. I THINK PERHAPS YOU'RE
GETTING AT THE OTHER SERVICES,
LIKE VIDEO CALLS, SO I JUST WANT
TO BE I WANTED TO BE CLEAR
BECAUSE IF YOUR POINT IS ABOUT
VOICE CALLING, THAT THE
TELEPHONE CALLING THAT THE
LEGISLATION HAD NO LIMITATIONS
AND THE VOICE CALLS AND I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR AS WELL. BOTH
BOTH TELEPHONE CALLS NATIONWIDE
AND INTERNATIONALLY ARE FREE.
THAT IS NOT THE CONCERN. OKAY.
THE CONCERN IS THE 20 MINUTE,
$0.20 PER MINUTE VIDEO CALLS.
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WHY WHY
THERE IS NO LIMITATION IN
REGARDS TO THIS. SO AGAIN IT
SAYS THE PRICE IS CHARGED TO THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION FOR
VARIOUS SERVICES IS LISTED IN
THE TABLE BELOW. AND LET ME
CLARIFY. SO THE UNDERSTANDING
HERE IS THAT THE PREMIUM
SERVICES ARE A AN INTEGRAL
COMPONENT OF THE LARGER BID FROM
VIAPATH FOR THE PROVISION OF
FREE CALLING. RIGHT. AND IS THAT
CORRECT? RIGHT. SO VIAPATH HAS
AGREED IN THE INITIAL
SOLICITATION, WE'RE GOING TO
PROVIDE FREE CALLING, BUT WE
WILL ALSO CONTRACT WITH CDCR TO
DO THE FOLLOWING. IS THAT ABOUT
RIGHT. SO THOSE THEY'RE BOUND
TOGETHER FOR. AND OUR CONCERN
HERE IS NOT ABOUT THE FREE VOICE
CALLING. IT'S ABOUT THAT
SECONDARY COMPONENT THAT THAT
MAY IN FACT BE THE BASIS FOR VÌ
PROFITABLE PROVISION OF THESE.
YES. AND I WANT TO SAY THAT THE
LEGISLATION AT HAND THAT YOU
REFERENCED IS SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
TELEPHONE CALLS BEING UNLIMITED,
WHICH WE SUPPORT. AND CLEARLY
IT'S FREE. IT'S THE OTHERS THAT
ARE NOT PART OF THAT LEGISLATION
THAT REQUIRES, AGAIN, ARE WE
SETTING PEOPLE UP FOR FAILURE OR
ARE WE SETTING UP THE STATE FOR
FAILURE? WHO IS GOING TO INCUR
THAT COST IF IT'S SO HIGH, THE
FAMILIES OF THE INMATE, WHAT IS
HAPPENING? AND THOSE ARE
INTERNAL POLICY DECISIONS THAT
CAN BE MADE, BECAUSE I'M
ASSUMING THE 15 MINUTE PHONE
CALLS ARE INTERNAL POLICIES. SO
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ON THE ON
THE VIDEO CALLS. AND FORGIVE ME,
I WAS REALLY FOCUSING ON THOSE
THOSE VOICE CALLS. BUT AS, AS
WAS MENTIONED WITH THE VIDEO
CALLS, THERE IS A KIOSK AND
THERE'S A STATION THAT THEY HAVE
TO GO TO ACTUALLY HAVE THOSE
VIDEOS, CALLS. THEY CAN'T DO
THOSE ANYWHERE. AND IT'S SET UP
FOR SECURITY REASONS. THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE LIMITED BY THE DAYROOM
SCHEDULE BECAUSE THOSE ARE ALL
INDOORS IN A HOUSING UNIT IN A
DAY ROOM. SO THOSE ARE LIMITED,
AND THOSE HAVE TO BE SHARED WITH
THE REST OF THE FOLKS LIVING IN
THAT HOUSING UNIT. SO THERE IS
SOME LIMITATION ON THOSE VOICE
CALLS. JUST OPERATIONALLY THEY
HAVE TO BE SIGNED UP AND PUT IN
IN, OKAY, GET THEIR TURN. IT'S
MUCH LIKE THE 15 MINUTE PHONE
CALL OF THE OLD WALL PHONES THAT
YOU SIGN UP FOR. SO I'M JUST
GOING TO LEAVE IT AT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS CLEAR ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT ON ENSURING
THERE'S SAFEGUARDS BOTH FOR THE
FAMILIES, THE INMATES, THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, OR BUDGET OR
VISION OF THIS PROGRAM, CLEARLY
THAT IS NOT CLEARLY ESTABLISHED
WITHIN THE INSTITUTION. AND I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS
IS A NEED FOR IMPROVEMENT AREA.
THIS ITEM IS BEING HELD OPEN,
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OUR FINAL ISSUE FOR DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU. ISSUE NUMBER 35,
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMING AND
EDUCATIONAL PANEL.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM PITZER COLLEGE PROFESSOR
NIGEL BOYLE. I THINK NIGEL
BOYLE. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
TECHNOLOGY PATHWAY PROGRAM.
SERGEANT WILL TURN YOU ON.
SENATE-TV ALL RIGHT. I'M SURE
YOUR MIC IS ON. OKAY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, MY NAME IS NIGEL
BOYLE. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
PITZER COLLEGE VÀ PATHWAY
PROGRAM AT THE CALIFORNIA
REHABILITATION CENTER IN NORCO,
LAST FRIDAY, MY COLLEAGUE
MARILYN RALSTON AND I MET WITH
THE TEN STUDENTS CGRTS THAT HAVE
COMMITTED TO BE MEMBERS OF OUR
FOURTH COHORT OF MATRICULATED
TRANSFER STUDENTS AT CRC. THAT
PHOTOGRAPH IS IN YOUR PACKET
THERE. PITZER ADMITS A COHORT OF
APPROXIMATELY TEN STUDENTS A
YEAR WHO WILL COMPLETE A DEGREE
IN AN 18 MONTH PERIOD. WE HAVE
100% SUCCESS RECORD, WITH
STUDENTS GRADUATING ON SCHEDULE,
AND ALL OF OUR GRADUATES WHO
HAVE PAROLED HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN, FINDING, WORK IN
PROFESSIONAL FIELDS, PROGRESSING
INTO GRADUATE SCHOOLS AND
WINNING FELLOWSHIPS, INCLUDING
TWO CAPITAL FELLOWSHIPS AND ONE
FULBRIGHT FELLOWSHIP. NOW THERE
ARE LOTS OF TERRIFIC BA PROGRAMS
GETTING OFF THE GROUND ACROSS
THE STATE, BUT THERE ARE THREE
UNIQUE FEATURES OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING AT CRC NORCO THAT WE WANT
YOU TO BE AWARE OF, CURRICULUM,
CONSORTIUM AND LOCATION, CAREER,
ARE OUR CURRICULUM IS INSIDE
OUT. THESE ARE REGULAR COLLEGES
AT THE CLAREMONT COLLEGES IN
WHICH WE BUS OUR OUTSIDE
STUDENTS INTO CRC TO BE TAUGHT
ALONGSIDE EQUAL NUMBERS OF
INCARCERATED STUDENTS. BOTH SETS
OF STUDENTS DO THE SAME WORK AND
EARN THE SAME CREDIT. THIS IS
FOR US, THE NEW FRONTIER IN
INTEGRATION. IN HIGHER
EDUCATION, LITERALLY NORMALIZING
HIGHER EDUCATION IN PRISON. AND
THIS IS THE ONLY BA PROGRAM IN
THE WORLD THAT'S BASED ON THIS,
THIS SORT OF CURRICULUM. SECOND,
OUR PROGRAM IS
MULTI-INSTITUTIONAL, THE INSIDE
OUT CURRICULUM THAT OUR STUDENTS
USE TO COMPLETE THEIR DEGREE
COMES FROM SEVEN DIFFERENT
COLLEGES THE FIVE CLAREMONT
COLLEGES, UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS
AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY, SAN
BERNARDINO. WE HAVE BUILT A
CONSORTIUM OF COLLABORATING FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS THAT BUILDS ON
THE TWO YEAR ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE
THAT NORCO COLLEGE FROM
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT DOES AT CRC. A THIRD
LOCATION, CRC, NORCO. AND THIS
IS IN, SENATOR SATO'S DISTRICT
IS UNIQUELY WELL PLACED TO BE
THE HUB FOR HIGHER EDUCATION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, LOCATED AT
THE INTERSECTION OF THE FOUR
COUNTIES TO WHICH MOST PEOPLE
WITHIN WITHIN CDCR. PAROLE. WE
HAVE A HIGHLY EFFECTIVE SCHOOL
IN THE PRISON, A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
NORCO COLLEGE, WHICH ARE
PIPELINING LARGE NUMBERS OF BA
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. NÓ CRC NORCO
HAS AN ARRAY OF CAL STATE èC
AND PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS, ALL IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY, WHO ARE ALL
WILLING TO ENGAGE AT CRC AND
ALSO TO COLLABORATE WITH ONE
ANOTHER. CDCR'S REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM REPORT REPORTED THAT CRC
LED THE STATE IN DEGREES AWARDED
OUR PRISONS LAST YEAR BY SOME
DISTANCE. IN FACT, THE
MULTI-INSTITUTIONAL
COLLABORATION ALREADY EXISTS AND
EXPANSION OF VÀ OPPORTUNITIES IS
UNDERWAY. LAST FRIDAY, WHEN WE
ADMITTED OUR FOURTH BA COHORT,
UC RIVERSIDE ADMITTED ITS FIRST
BA COHORT WITH FULL SUPPORT FROM
CRC WARDEN PRATT. WE ARE NOW
FORMING A PLANNING GROUP, WHICH
WILL SPEND THE NEXT YEAR WORKING
ON A PROPOSAL TO CONVERT AN
ENTIRE SECTION OF THE PRISON
THAT SENATOR NEWMAN AND SENATOR
RUSSO HAVE ALREADY VISITED. AND
I UNDERSTAND CIERTO IS SITTING
SHORTLY, TO CONVERT THIS SECTION
OF THE PRISON TO A COLLEGE
CENTER FOR MULTIPLE INSTITUTIONS
ADMITTING MULTIPLE COHORTS OF BA
STUDENTS IN 2025 AND BEYOND.
THIS PLANNING GROUP WILL BRING
TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS FROM
PITZER COLLEGE, NORCO COLLEGE,
CAL STATE, SAN BERNARDINO, UC
RIVERSIDE, REDLANDS AND CRC AND
WE HOPE TO BRING THAT PLAN TO
YOU SOON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR AND HONORABLE COMMITTEE.
NELSON MANDELA ONCE SAID,
EDUCATION IS THE MOST POWERFUL
WEAPON ONE CAN USE TO CHANGE THE
WORLD. MY NAME IS ROMERO AND
RALSTON, AND I'M A FORMER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PROJECT
REBOUND AT CAL STATE UNIVERSITY,
FULLERTON, AND THE CURRENT
SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR THE JUSTICE
EDUCATION CENTER FOR THE
CLAREMONT COLLEGES, THE JUSTICE
EDUCATION CENTER IS THE
EXPANSION OF THE JUSTICE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE THAT WAS
LAUNCHED IN 2020. THROUGH THE
SUPPORT OF A MELLON GRANT UNDER
THE IMAGINING FREEDOMS FUND, OUR
INSIDE OUT CURRICULUM AND VÀ
PROGRAM IS BUILDING UPON
GROUNDBREAKING WORK ACROSS THE
SIX CLAREMONT COLLEGES WITHIN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION.
I COME TO THIS WORK AS A BLACK
FEMINIST, ABOLITIONIST SCHOLAR
WITH AN INCARCERATION EXPERIENCE
. AT AGE 24, I WAS SENTENCED TO
LIFE IN PRISON AND SERVED 23
YEARS AT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN IN CORONA.
WHILE IN PRISON, MY PEERS
INTRODUCED ME TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND ENCOURAGED ME TO
ENROLL IN COLLEGE CLASSES, AND I
HAVE BEEN A LIFELONG LEARNER
EVER SINCE ATTENDING FACE TO
FACE COLLEGE CLASSES IN PRISON,
UNPACKING THEORY, AND HAVING
SPIRITED AND RICH DISCUSSIONS
WITH MY PEERS ABOUT RACE, CLASS,
AND ETHICS ALLOWED ME TO SEE
MYSELF, OTHERS, AND THE SOCIAL
CONDITIONS THAT WE WERE
SUFFERING DIFFERENTLY. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY, HIGHER EDUCATION
GAVE ME HOPE AND PURPOSE. EVEN
AFTER THE ENACTMENT OF THE 94
CRIME BILL, WHICH DISAVOWED
ACCESS TO PELL GRANT FUNDS FOR
INCARCERATED STUDENTS, CAUSING
MANY COLLEGE PROGRAMS TO PULL
THEIR DEGREE BEARING PROGRAMS
FROM PRISONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I NEVER LOST MY THIRST FOR
KNOWLEDGE DURING THOSE DARK
YEARS WITHOUT THE COLLEGE
PROGRAMS THAT CIW, A NUMBER OF
CLAREMONT COLLEGE PROFESSORS
BEGAN TEACHING WRITING WORKSHOPS
AND PARTICIPATING IN OUR
PROGRAMING BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTOOD THE TRANSFORMATIVE
POWER OF HIGHER EDUCATION. IN
2011, I WAS RELEASED AND PAROLED
TO CLAREMONT IN LA COUNTY. I
REMEMBERED HOW ENGAGING AND
COMMITTED THOSE PROFESSORS WERE
WHEN I WAS INSIDE, AND DECIDED
TO EMAIL A FEW TO ASK FOR ADVICE
AND MENTORING. IT WAS NO
SURPRISE THAT THEY WELCOMED ME
HOME AND OFFERED ME A SEAT IN
THEIR CLASSES TO OBSERVE AND
BUILD COMMUNITY. THEN ONE DAY, A
SCRIPPS PROFESSOR WHOSE CLASS I
WAS OBSERVING SUGGESTED I APPLY
TO THE PITZER COLLEGE NEW
RESOURCES PROGRAM FOR
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS. I
DIDN'T THINK IT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE THAT I COULD BE
ADMITTED, BUT I WAS. AND AT AGE
50, I EARNED MY BACHELOR'S
DEGREE WITH HONORS AND GENDER
AND FEMINIST STUDIES, AND I WAS
NOMINATED BY THE COLLEGE FOR A
NAPIER FELLOWSHIP IN PEACE AND
JUSTICE AND AWARDED A CHORAL
FELLOWSHIP IN PUBLIC AFFAIRS.
THEN WENT ON TO GRADUATE SCHOOL
AT WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY IN
SAINT LOUIS, EARNING A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN LETTERS AND SCIENCE.
IS. WHAT I'M TRYING TO SAY IS
THAT IT'S NEVER TOO LATE TO
LEARN, AND IT'S NEVER TOO LATE
TO BE THE CHANGE YOU WANT TO
SEE. IN CLOSING, ALTHOUGH MY
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY BEGAN AS A
LIFER IN PRISON, MY LIFE WAS
CHANGED BECAUSE OF MY EDUCATION
AT PITZER COLLEGE AND THE
COMMUNITY OF SUPPORT THEY
OFFERED WITH THEIR STANDING
REPUTATION IN THE WORLD AS A
PROMINENT PRIVATE LIBERAL ARTS
SCHOOL, I HAVE NOT ONLY
REINVENTED MY LIFE, BUT I HAVE
ALSO ASSISTED HUNDREDS OF
STUDENTS WITHIN INCARCERATION
EXPERIENCE, REIMAGINE THEIRS
THROUGH POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. PITZER COLLEGE TAUGHT
ME THE VALUE OF SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY INTER CULTURAL
LEARNING, ENVIRONMENTAL
SUSTAINABILITY, STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT, AND
INTERDISCIPLINARY LEARNING.
THANK YOU. AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE JUSTICE EDUCATION CENTER, I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
PROJECT REBOUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR, AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE TODAY AND
REPRESENT PROJECT REBOUND. MY
NAME IS AARON GREEN. I'M A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL
WHO SERVED TEN YEARS BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
NEVADA AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS HERE
WITH CDCR. I WAS RELEASED FROM
PRISON IN 2015, AND I WENT ON
THROUGH PROJECT REBOUND TO
ACHIEVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
PSYCHOLOGY, SUMMA LAUDE, WITH A
3.96 GPA AND A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN PSYCHOLOGY AT FRESNO STATE.
WITH THE PROJECT REBOUND WITH A
4.0 GPA, AND I AM NOW THE
DIRECTOR OF PROJECT REBOUND
SACRAMENTO, PROJECT REBOUND AT
SAC STATE AND ALSO A DOCTORAL
CANDIDATE WITH THE EDUCATIONAL
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM. I'M ALSO A
SINGLE FATHER OF TWO CHILDREN.
ONE IS A D1 SPORTS. HÌ FELL IN,
12TH GRADE HERE AT IN ELK GROVE
AND MY DAUGHTER IS AT CSUSB,
WITH A 4.0 GPA STUDYING ART AND
WILL BE TRANSFERRING TO
SACRAMENTO STATE PROJECT
REBOUND. IF YOU DON'T KNOW HIS,
BEEN AROUND SINCE 1967 ASSISTING
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND DOING
CORRESPONDENCE WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE READY TO COME OUT AND
RECEIVE AN EDUCATION, OF COURSE
WE ARE RIGHT NOW WORKING WITH A
FEW DIFFERENT PROCESSES AS WE DO
THIS PROGRAM CALLED CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY PROJECT REBOUND
WITH INSIDE THE CDCR, WHERE WE
BRING IN INFORMATION ABOUT
PROJECT REBOUND TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE INCARCERATED AND PERFORM
EIGHT WEEKS OF WORKSHOPS OVER A
TWO AND A HALF TO THREE MONTH
PERIOD OF TIME, WITH A
CULMINATING EVENT THAT ALLOWS
STUDENTS TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROGRAM AND UNDERSTANDING OF ALL
THE PIECES OF BECOMING A
STUDENT, INCLUDING FINANCIAL
RESOURCES, FINANCIAL AID,
FINANCIAL LITERACY, BUDGETING
PROCESSES, APPLICATION RETENTION
, AND ADMISSIONS INTO THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. WE HAVE
PULLED OUT PROBABLY ABOUT 175
STUDENTS IN THE PAST SIX MONTHS
FROM THOSE PROGRAMS AND GOT THEM
INTO OUR PROJECT REBOUNDS AT
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES. ON TOP OF
THAT, WE ALSO HAVE TRANSFORMING
OUTCOMES PROGRAM AT SACRAMENTO
STATE, WHICH IS A FOUR YEAR
BACHELOR'S PROGRAM WITH A FOUR
YEAR BACHELOR'S PROGRAM. WE ARE
AT MULE CREEK IN FOLSOM RIGHT
NOW, AND THAT IS A
COMMUNICATIONS DEGREE IN, A
FULLY MATRICULATED PROCESS. THE
STUDENTS CAN LEAVE THERE AND
COME DIRECTLY TO CAMPUS AT ANY
GIVEN TIME AND CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION. WE WILL BE AT CMF AND
AT SOLANO WITHIN THE NEXT YEAR
AND A HALF WITH ANOTHER
BACHELOR'S PROGRAM THAT WILL BE
FOR THE HONORS IN LAW AND
SOCIETY, WE ALSO WORK WITH
JUVENILE JUSTICE INVOLVED
STUDENTS AT DIFFERENT AREA
LOCATIONS FROM SACRAMENTO, SAN
JOAQUIN, SOLANO AND SONOMA
COUNTY. WE DO HAVE STUDENTS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE CENTER IN SAN
JOAQUIN, TAKING A FULL FOUR YEAR
BACHELOR'S PROGRAM ONLINE. WE
HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE IN CMF OR
CMF, BUT, SOLANO THAT ARE
ACTUALLY NOW BEING TRANSPORTED
TO SACRAMENTO STATE STARTING IN
AUGUST. WE ALSO OFFER A STEP
DOWN PROGRAM THROUGH THE
JUVENILE COURTS, WHICH ALLOWS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN THE
JUVENILE FACILITIES TO BE
RELEASED TO OUR CUSTODY AND STAY
IN THE TWO HOUSES THAT WE HAVE
AT SACRAMENTO STATE AND PROVIDE
THE STUDENTS WITH AN EDUCATION.
SO WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO CREATE A
SPACE WHERE ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND
ACCESS TO EDUCATION. WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING GOES RIGHT. WE NEED
MORE HOUSING, OF COURSE, BECAUSE
BOTH OF THE HOUSES THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW ARE COMPLETELY FULL,
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN. WHEN I STARTED AT
SACRAMENTO STATE, WE HAD 38
STUDENTS. WE HAD NOW HAVE 178
WITH 17 GRADUATING WITH MASTER'S
AND BACHELOR'S, PLUS 30 MORE
THAT ARE REGISTERED TO COME ON.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
POLICE FOR GREECE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
I AM CHRISTINA BROWN MENDOZA,
ACTING EXECUTIVE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PLACE FOR GREECE
. HAVING PERSONALLY ENDURED THE
ANGUISH OF SEPARATION DUE TO
INCARCERATION, I UNDERSTAND
FIRSTHAND THE PROFOUND TOLL IT
TAKES ON FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN. PROGRAMS LIKE THE
PLACE FOR GRACE, CAMP GRACE PLAY
AN INDISPENSABLE ROLE IN
FACILITATING FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND HEALING TRAUMA
CAUSED BY INCARCERATION. THÀNH
BY OFFERING A NURTURING,
RESTORATIVE ENVIRONMENT WHERE
CHILDREN AND THEIR PARENTS CAN
UNITE, SHARE EXPERIENCES, AND
PARTICIPATE IN ART HEALING
ACTIVITIES. THESE PROGRAMS
EFFECTIVELY MEND FRACTURED
RELATIONSHIPS AND FOSTER
STRONGER BONDS. ADDITIONALLY,
INITIATIVES WITHIN CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES THAT PRIORITIZE
REHABILITATION, AN EDUCATION AND
SKILL BUILDING ARE PIVOTAL IN
REDUCING RECIDIVISM RATES BY
EMPOWERING INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
TOOLS THEY NEED TO SUCCESSFULLY
REINTEGRATE INTO SOCIETY. THESE
PROGRAMS NOT ONLY INSPIRE HOPE
FOR A BETTER FUTURE, BUT ALSO
ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY. INVESTING
IN SUCH INITIATIVES ISN'T MERELY
ABOUT AIDING TO THOSE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED. IT'S ABOUT
CULTIVATING A SAFER, MORE
COHESIVE COMMUNITY FOR ALL. IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE THE PLACE FOR GRACE RECEIVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO SUSTAIN
THEIR IMPACTFUL WORK. TP, KNOWN
AS TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMING,
WORKS AS A COALITION OF 99
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OFFERING REHABILITATIVE, TRAUMA
INFORMED HEALING PROGRAMS IN ALL
34 CDCR FACILITIES. TP HAS
CHAMPIONED ADEQUATE STATE
FUNDING AND IS CURRENTLY
PROPOSING A $20 MILLION
ALLOCATION INTO THE RIGHT GRANT
3.0, SUPPORTED BY COMPELLING
EVIDENCE. RECENT DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
UNDERSCORES THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
SUCH PROGRAMS IN REDUCING
RECIDIVISM RATES. THESE FINDINGS
AFFIRM THE POSITIVE IMPACT OF
PROP 57 AND CBO REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS AS THE PLACE FOR GRACE
CAMP GRACE PROGRAM, WHICH SERVES
, SERVES INCARCERATED PARENTS
AND THEIR CHILDREN, STANDS OUT
DUE TO ITS DISTINCTIVE FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES KNOWN AS ACES. SUCH
ABUSE, NEGLECT, OR HOUSEHOLD
DYSFUNCTION BEFORE THE AGE OF 18
CAN HAVE ENDURING EFFECTS ON
ADOLESCENTS PSYCHOLOGICAL,
PHYSIOLOGICAL, AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH. STATISTICS SHOW THAT
CHILDREN OF INCARCERATED PARENTS
ARE SIX TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BECOME INCARCERATED AT SOME
POINT OF THEIR LIVES. CAMP GRACE
AIMS TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
INTERGENERATIONAL TRAUMA OFTEN
OBSERVED IN FAMILIES AFFECTED BY
INCARCERATION, MITIGATING THE
ADVERSE IMPACT AND FOSTERING
RESILIENCE IN CHILDREN WITH
INCARCERATED PARENTS. CAMP GRACE
IS THE SOLE PROGRAM OF ITS KIND
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UNLIKE CONVENTIONAL PROGRAMS
OFFERED WITHIN CDCR, CAMP GRACE
PROVIDES A RARE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INCARCERATED PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN TO SPEND EXTENDED TIME
TO BOND AND HEAL WITHOUT THE
OTHER CARETAKER PRESENT OUTSIDE
OF THE STRICT GUIDELINES OF
REGULAR VISITATION, THIS
APPROACH EMPHASIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY CONNECTION
AND REHABILITATION PROCESS, AND
OFFERS A HAND ON APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES FACED
BY INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. CAMP GRACE HAS A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CHILDREN. THE
EXPERIENCE PROVIDES THEM WITH A
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY WHILE
ENGAGING IN FUN, ART, MUSIC, AND
MEANINGFUL ACTIVITIES ALONGSIDE
THEIR PARENT AND OTHER CHILDREN
OF INCARCERATED PARENTS. CAMP
GRACE BECOMES A SANCTUARY WHERE
UNLIMITED MOMENTS OF
TOGETHERNESS ARE CHERISHED,
WHERE PLAYING CATCH WITH A REAL
BALL BECOMES A SYMBOL OF JOY AND
NORMALCY, WHICH IS SUCH A STARK
CONTRAST TO THE MAKESHIFT GAMES
IN A PRISON VISITING ROOM. THE
CHILDREN BUILD CONFIDENCE AND A
SENSE OF BELONGING, FOSTERING
HEALING, CONNECTION AND GROWTH
FOR INCARCERATED PARENTS. CAMP
GRACE OFFERS A CHANCE TO
RECONNECT WITH THEIR CHILDREN IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY, ALLOWING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAL AND
BEGIN MENDING THE PROCESS OF
REBUILDING TRUST WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. THIS OPPORTUNITY CAN
GIVE THE INCARCERATED PERSONS
HOPE PURPOSE WHICH IS PIVOTAL
TOWARDS POSITIVE CHANGE.
ADDITION ORPHALI THE SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT OF CAMP GRACE
PROVIDES INCARCERATED PARENTS
WITH A SPACE TO REFLECT ON THEIR
ACTIONS, SET POSITIVE EXAMPLES
FOR THEIR CHILDREN, AND ENVISION
A BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR THEIR
FAMILY. TODAY IT IS IMPERATIVE
FOR PROGRAMS LIKE OURS AND THOSE
UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF TPW TO
RECEIVE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR THE
LIFE CHANGING WORK THAT WE ARE
ALL DOING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION,
COLLEAGUES, DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? SENATOR NEWMAN, I DO
SO. SO, YOU KNOW, FIRST, THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
SECONDLY, THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR PROVIDING TIME FOR
THESE PROGRAMS. I HAVE
PERSONALLY VISITED WITH EACH OF
THESE PROGRAMS. I CAN PERSONALLY
ATTEST TO THE POWERFUL WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING, TO PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THEY'RE HERE TODAY. WE
TALKED TO MR. LEWIS FROM SAN
QUENTIN. WE'VE GOT $240 MILLION
GOING INTO THE SAN QUENTIN
EXPERIMENT. THAT'S WONDERFUL.
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM EACH OF
YOU. HOW MUCH? HOW MUCH? BY WAY
OF FUNDS ARE YOU RECEIVING FROM
THE STATE RIGHT NOW FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING? ZERO. MISS
MENDOZA, I'LL HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU WITH AN EXACT NUMBER. A
LOT OF OUR FUNDING IS ALREADY
COMING TO AN END BECAUSE WE'RE
NO LONGER CONSIDERED INNOVATIVE.
MR. SO, THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
PIECES TO THAT. THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE SENATE BILL
FROM LÀ ARE IN THE BUDGET FROM
LAST YEAR. DID GIVE PROJECT
REBOUND $11.3 MILLION TO SUSTAIN
20 OF OUR CAMPUSES. THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE UP TO RIGHT NOW IS 20
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE A PROJECT
REBOUND AS FAR AS CDCR GOES. WE
HAVE APPLIED FOR INNOVATIVE
GRANTS THROUGH OUR CSU PROP, AND
THEY HAVE GIVEN US, MAYBE 350 OR
$400,000 OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS TO BE ABLE TO BRING IN CSU
PROP INTO THE PRISONS, BECAUSE
IT'S AN EXPENSIVE PROCESS TO
PRINT PAPERS AND BRING IN
INFORMATION, HIRING STAFF AND
STUFF LIKE THAT. THANK YOU, ONE
GOOD THING ABOUT IT IS, OF
COURSE, A LOT OF OUR, PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS, THE ONES THAT ARE
WORKING PROPERLY, DO HAVE
CALIFORNIA STATE IDS. SO I
ACTUALLY HAVE A CDCR BADGE THAT
ALLOWS ME IN. THANK YOU. AND SO
IF YOU ALSO MIGHT TALK ABOUT
RECIDIVISM RATES, SO, YOU KNOW,
SO PROJECT REBOUND FIRST YOUR
RECIDIVISM RATE YOU TRACK IT.
OUR RECIDIVISM RATE IS LESS THAN
1% THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LESS
THAN 1% IN SET OUT ZERO ZERO,
AND YOURS IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. MISS MENDOZA. BUT LET
LET ME SAY, YOU KNOW, HAVING
VISITED ALL THESE PROGRAMS AND
HAVING TALKED TO THE WARDENS AT
EACH FACILITY, THESE ARE
IMMENSELY POSITIVE, RIGHT? ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS. ONE, PROVIDING
INCENTIVES FOR INMATES TO FIND A
PATHWAY WHILE INCARCERATED.
SECOND, TO YOUR POINT, FOR
PATHWAYS AFTER AFTER
INCARCERATION THAT PROVIDE FOR
EFFECTIVELY NO RECIDIVISM AT
ALL. AND THE THIRD, WHICH I
THINK IS REALLY STUNNING, IS THE
DEGREE TO WHICH IT CHANGES THE
DYNAMIC WITHIN THE WALLS. AND
I'VE HEARD FROM EVERY SINGLE
WARDEN WHO PARTICIPATES IN THESE
PROGRAMS THAT IT HAS A
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE ON HOW
INMATES AND CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS DEAL WITH EACH OTHER.
AND THAT'S AN IMMENSELY POSITIVE
THING, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
STRESSES THAT CEOS FACE. AND SO
I WOULD SUBMIT TO THIS FIRST,
EVERY COLLEAGUE SHOULD GO VISIT
THESE PROGRAMS. THEY ARE
AMAZING. BUT WITHIN THAT LARGER
BUDGET FOR CDCR, WE HAVE TO FIND
MONEY FOR PROGRAMS LIKE THIS,
AND SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR
DURAZO, I JUST WANT TO DITTO,
HAVING VISITED NORCO AND SPOKEN
TO A LOT OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THERE, IT'S PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY. SO THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU KIND OF PUT ME TO SHAME WITH
ALL THOSE DEGREES. THANK YOU, I
DO JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO THE REENTRY AND THE
PROGRAMING, AND I WANT TO MAKE
THIS VERY CLEAR THAT THIS IS
HOPEFULLY A GOAL. WE CONSTANTLY
TALK ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY AND
INCARCERATION, BUT WE DO NOT
TALK ABOUT THE OTHER ARM OF
PUBLIC SAFETY IS AND IT'S TO
MAKE A GOOD NEIGHBOR, AS THE
NORWEGIAN SAY, SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. AND AS AN
ADVOCATE OF EDUCATION AT ALL
INCOMES, AND LEVELS, I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY EDUCATION CRADLE TO
GRAVE IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL HUMAN
BEINGS. SO THANK YOU. THIS IS
JUST AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM, SO
NO ACTION IS NEEDED. WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS ABOUT ANY OF THE
ISSUES? SENATOR DURAZZO THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I HAVE A
QUESTION OR COMMENT WITH, ISSUE
TWO, THE ADMINISTRATION PROGRAM
SUPPORT OF CALTRANS, IF THERE'S
ANYBODY STILL HERE FROM
CALTRANS, IF YOU CAN COME UP AND
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION, PLEASE. CERTAINLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. STEPHEN KECK
WITH CALTRANS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO IN 2022, WE
EXTENDED THE DGS AND CALTRANS
PILOT PROGRAM FOR BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT, AND WE REQUIRED A
REPORT ON SUPPLIERS COMMITMENTS
TO PROVIDING JOBS. THAT REPORT
WAS DUE THIS PAST MARCH 1ST. SO
I'D LIKE TO GET YOUR FOCUS ON
THAT, I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
DISAGREEMENT OVER THE, BEST
VALUE PROCUREMENT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY. I THINK WE ALL
AGREE WITH THAT, BUT IT'S TO
MAKE THIS FLEET REPLACEMENT, IN
CALIFORNIA, THE GREENEST STATE
FLEET IN THE COUNTRY. SO I WOULD
LIKE FOR YOU TO PLEASE PROVIDE
MY OFFICE WITH A LIST OF YOUR
VEHICLE NEEDS, YOUR SPECIALIZED
VEHICLE, PURCHASES, AND YOUR
VERSATILE, CUSTOMIZATIONS, AND
WHERE IS, BEST VALUE BEING USED
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS? SO YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER IT ALL
TODAY. YOU CAN DO A QUICKIE, BUT
IF YOU CAN GIVE MORE DETAIL TO
MY OFFICE, I APPRECIATE THAT.
CERTAINLY SENATOR. SO FIRST I'D
LIKE TO SAY, IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SINCE THAT
BILL WAS ENACTED, THERE HAVE NOT
BEEN ANY PURCHASES THROUGH DGS
USING BEST VALUE PRACTICES. AND
THAT'S, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S ONLY
BEEN ABOUT A YEAR AND A FEW
MONTHS SINCE THAT, BILL WENT
INTO EFFECT, AND OUR FIRST PHASE
OF FLEET REPLACEMENT WAS LIGHT
DUTY FLEET, WHICH WAS REQUIRED
TO BE PURCHASED THROUGH DGS
STATEWIDE CONTRACTS. AND THE
SECOND PHASE, WE'LL BE FOCUSING
ON MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FLEETS,
AND WE PLAN TO USE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT FOR AT LEAST 50% OF
THOSE VEHICLES THAT ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THAT STATEWIDE FLEET
REQUIREMENT. SO YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. WE'RE VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO USING
IT, BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO,
TO USE IT ON THOSE, THOSE TYPES
OF VEHICLES THAT ARE MORE
SPECIALTY IN NATURE. SO YOU'LL
SEE A LOT MORE OF THAT, IN THIS
SECOND PHASE BEGINNING NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AGAIN. I SAY THIS IN EVERY
MEETING. SO TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS HAD A CHANCE TO BE
HEARD, PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO 30S. AND IF SOMEONE
ELSE HAS ALREADY MADE A SIMILAR
COMMENT, PLEASE JUST ADD A ME
TOO, WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AT
THAT, MIC AGAIN. 30S YOU GUYS
ARE ALL GOING TO BE TIMED. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON DANICA.
RADAMEL, ON BEHALF OF
TRANSFORMATIVE PROGRAMING WORKS
AND INITIATE JUSTICE, IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF INCREASED STATE
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS, EDUCATION
AND REENTRY, PARTICULARLY BY
FINDING AREA IN CDCR. S BUDGET
WHERE THERE MAY BE FUNDING THAT
CAN BE TRANSFERRED OVER TO THAT
AND ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AROUND THE STATE
, ENSURING THAT WE'RE GETTING
THE BEST POSSIBLE RATES FOR,
BOTH THE STATE AND FOR IMPACTED
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF PAYING FOR
TABLETS AND COMMUNICATION
SERVICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS,
CAPRI WALKER, ON BEHALF OF
INSIGHT GARDEN PROGRAM, OUR
CURRENT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HAS
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN SUPPORTING
BASIC NEEDS FUNDING FOR
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
AT PROJECT REBOUND ACROSS
MULTIPLE CSU CAMPUSES TODAY, I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR REISSUING THE UNUSED
FUNDING BACK TO PROJECT REBOUND
AND THE CSU. WE STRONGLY URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO REISSUE THE
REMAINING $3 MILLION BACK TO THE
CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO SERVE
OUR MOST HOUSING INSECURE
STUDENTS EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MEMBERS,
IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, SEEING NONE, THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY, PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO A VOTE ONLY CALENDAR,
AND SO FIRST THAT WE WILL WILL
VOTE ON ISSUES. AND AGAIN, IT'S
IN THE AGENDA. SO I'M JUST GOING
TO BUY ISSUES NUMBER ISSUES 357
THROUGH TEN, 13, 14 AND 17
THROUGH 27. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THESE
ISSUES. SO MOVED BY SENATOR
DURAZO, COULD WE CALL FOR A ROLL
? SENATORS WILLIAM AYE, SENATOR
DURAZZO NEWMAN SEYARTO. HI.
THANK YOU. THAT MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
AND IT HAS, PASSED, WE'RE NOW
GOING TO MOVE ON TO VOTE ON
ISSUES ONE, TWO, FOUR, SIX, SIX,
11, 12, 15, 16 AND 29. DO I HAVE
A MOTION MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN? THE MOTION IS TO ADOPT
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS. CAN I
HAVE A ROLL CALL, SENATORS
WAHAB. AYE NEWMAN. CIERTO. THANK
YOU, THE MOTION HAS BEEN ADOPTED
AND WILL MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE, NOW WE'RE GOING TO
VOTE ON ISSUE NUMBER 28. DO I
HAVE A MOTION? SO MOVED. MOVED
BY SENATOR DURAZZO. CAN WE GET A
ROLL CALL? VOTE, PLEASE.
SENATORS WAHAB. AYE DURAZZO.
NEWMAN. SATO THANK YOU. THAT
MOTION HAS BEEN ADOPTED. AND
MOVING OUT OF COMMITTEE. AGAIN,
I DO APPRECIATE EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION. THÀNH. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE, NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY
AND JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION IS ADJOURNED